thank you representative Gilman uh this
morning we have a sub clerk
representative majori will be clerking
for us today
in um rep McDonald's absence so we will
ask our clerk to call a rooll please
thank you Mr
chairman um chairman turot here Vice
chairman power
here representative Guthrie here
representative McDonald is not here
representative lales here representative
yella not here representative
Kelly representative Alward here
representative Brown here representative
Cahill here representative stavis is not
here repres representative
Tetro
here representative tree L is not here
representative Gilman here
representative majori myself I am here
representative
Gallagher here representative Hicks I'm
here representative Howland here
representative priest yes here
representative Frack present thank you
very
much thank you Mr clerk uh all right
today we have several hearings we have
one uh quick bill that we're going to
EXA and prior to that we have somebody
who would like to address our committee
representative
Reed thank you so much Mr chair and
honorable members of the committee um I
asked the chair if he would um allow me
the opportunity to apologize to all of
you
and he very graciously agreed um so two
weeks ago I had a bill before you and
you all have almost always treated me
with respect and professionalism and
heard my bills and and with a great deal
of of reason and um at the time someone
had uh testified against my bill and in
in that moment I felt very strongly that
um that person's testimony had
mischaracterized the bill and so I went
out into the Hall to speak with him
about that and um I was assertive and uh
probably tonal and even confrontational
with him but I want to be clear that
that was not what you all heard um when
he asked me to be quiet I was primed in
a in a mental state to interpret that in
the worst possible way um as if he was
being patronizing and I extremely loudly
in fact at the top of my lungs shouted
um and that was extremely unprofessional
of me I disrespected him I disrespected
this committee's work and I disrespected
the um proper procedure of the house and
for that I have to offer my um deepest
apologies to you all for doing that um I
want to be I I called Mr Klein last week
to apologize to him Direct directly and
we actually had a very good 15-minute
phone conversation he treated me with a
great deal of Grace and equin equinity
and reason and he said that he
understood why I would be um upset in
the moment and interpret things the way
I did he gave me his word that he did
not mean to be patronizing or sexist and
asking me to be quiet that it was he
would have said the same thing to anyone
and I take him at his word having no
other reason to believe him to be that
kind of person and I believe that um he
is sincere in saying that so I want to
commend him for treating me graciously
and um and make sure it's on record that
I do not believe that he was being
patronizing and that I do apologize to
this committee and I also would like it
as a matter of record that I certainly
did not intend to um treat anyone
differently because of a difference of
viewpoint that that it was specifically
that that I was responding to in my
incorrect In My incorrect interpretation
that I welcome disagreements and
engagement um with Civility and uh in
fact I believe that I have co-sponsored
and and testified for a great number of
bills from people of the opposite party
so I want to reaffirm my belief in
working with people who disagree and
once again very very deeply apologize to
this committee for disrupting you and
disrespecting you and disrespecting the
witnesses that came before you thank you
so much for this time that you've given
me thank you
representative okay uh we are going to
start out by opening an executive
session on a house bill
1708 FN relative to local records
retention um
power thank you Mr chair I'd like to
make a motion of inexpedient to
legislate on House Bill
1708 and could somebody want to second
that representative pre-cs
that um I'll just briefly speak to that
for you um HP 1708 the guts of the bill
was um
incorporated into a Judiciary Bill and
that one I believe now has according to
uh chairman Lynn has been completely
brought into one of their bills and has
either made its way or is about to make
its way through the committee so this is
a a early Bill we have to get it done
today so we can get it reported out of
committee that's the reason why we're it
tailing this there any comments on this
represent
gar um i'
just uh like to note that I supported
the original Bill and would have
preferred it if we could have passed it
ourselves um the whole procedure here of
handing it off to the
Judiciary I think
um I I I'm just going to say I'm not
very happy with but um that being said
if the prime sponsors on board um
then fine let's itl it um but I do wish
we could have passed ourselves
though thank you just to be clear
representative Gallagher we didn't hand
it to them the um chairman of Judiciary
requested that we allow them to put the
guts of this bill in there I believe we
I spoke with the prime sponsor and he
did not have any opposition to
that all right any other
comments
okay uh ask the clerk to call a rooll
please thank you Mr chairman the motion
is itl on House Bill
1708 um Vice chairman power
yes representative Guthrie
yes representative McDonald is not here
representative lales yes representative
yella yes representative Kelly is not
here representative
Alward yes representative Brown yes
representative kahill yes representative
stavis is not here should sorry
representative Tetro yes representa trle
is not here representative Gilman yes
representative majori myself will be
voting yes representative
Gallagher yes representative Hicks yes
yes representative Howland yes
representative priest yes representative
Frack yes and Mr chairman yes the motion
passes unanimously
160 Thank you Mr clerk without objection
this will go on to the consent calendar
seeing no
objections it will go on the consent
calendar and I'll write a quick blurb to
get that in and that closes the exec
session on E8 House Bill 110
S no excuse 1708
1708 okay we will open up the public
hearing on HB 1106 relative to net asset
limits under the elderly property tax
exemption I see the prime sponsor has
taken the seat represent representative
erery you are
up for
what whatever you would like to
say thank you for the record my name is
Jordan erery representing Hillsboro 13
town of Hudson New Hampshire uh this
started off as a mere uh housekeeping
measure because the limits
on um the elderly exemption haven't been
changed in something in like 30 years as
a matter of fact if you take a look at
the strikeout for the numbers uh it's
somewhere around $1,000 for a single
individual somebody who is on Medicare
only as their uh form of U
supplement receiving roughly $2,000
would receive $24,000 so they're don't
meet the minimum
requirement because there's been no
adjustment of the require of the
minimums for married or single
applicants in a long period of time that
needs to be addressed or there needs to
be an addition to this addressing it to
the CPI or in some fashion like that I
know that over and Ways and Means we've
done that several times with various
uh taxation programs so that we can
maintain a uh business deduction uh of
businesses based on the uh inflationary
value or devaluation of our
currency that was the primary thing then
as we got into it I looked add it this
section of law from both the ways and
means side and from the fact that I'm a
senior and there's a lot of people that
in town that come up to me in one of the
two coffee shops or three coffee shops
now uh saying uh can't get don't know
how why is that type of question we've
all received that kind of question and
we all know we take a look at it to see
what uh the situation is before we go
forward and in this particular instance
I found the elderly in my community are
being driven out of their homes quite
literally driven out of the community
because of an inability to pay in a
rapid diminu of their resources as we
live
longer I'm approaching the maximum uh
age uh M fact I've exceeded the age of
death that was actually
actuar stated when I was born so
and I look around the room and there's
one or two other people that are in that
same
category this is something that the
legislature has not addressed regarding
such programs whether or not giving
elderly or the veterans or the blind or
that's not the policy the policy is
already in place the PO the question
here is what are the requirements to
qualify and nothing else changes on this
because it's up to the communities to
adopt
this all we're doing is increasing the
level at which the communities can
adopt now I'm just crusing some notes
that were handed to me earlier and then
there's a couple of uh questions
regarding wording Etc uh you everyone is
aware of the fact that uh uh legislation
is created by attorneys that uh they use
their language they use their best
interpretation of which section of law
applies whether they made a mistake or
not we can adjust that as we go along uh
but as you know that's that's uh
something that uh that takes care uh
that is taken care of in uh a variety of
off reccord
committees
by
eliminating the current minimums and
essentially doubling them I used round
number to double it up to a round
number um we are creating more people
may be coming eligible for it but we're
also allowing more older people who are
on a fixed income to remain in their
houses for that
time by modifying the fixed
assets we're allowing them to enjoy that
period of time so that they
can uh continue to live in their Pro
their homes and they can continue to
participate in the community by perhaps
going out to dinner once in a while
going out to breakfast once in a while
buying
groceries once in a
while that is an issue in my community
even though Hudson has a reputation of
not being one of the PO poorer
communities in the uh area there are
still individuals
that occasionally need some
assistance by modifying that those areas
we're allowing people to stay in their
homes for the rest of their natural
lives but we've also capped the amount
of uh tax deductions that we've included
in
here so try to balance between the two
and I hope that the committee will look
favorably upon
this I hate to say it but it's for the
old
folks I'll be glad to answer any
questions Mr chair okay thank you
representative yok
Kella thank you and thank you for taking
the question um it seems like the
law allows it to that the town or city
choose any amount as long it is not less
than um the amount stated and so by
increasing that amount you're actually
reducing the amount the option of the of
the towns and cities to choose a number
let's say less than the number that
you've chosen and greater than the
current number um I'm looking at lines
25 and
26 would
you what is your opposition to towns
choosing let's say 20 5,000 as the
number that they choose what why why
should a town not be able to do
that I'm not reading that the same
manner in which you're reading it
um but 25,000 30,000 and I'm no
objection that particular number needs
to be increased to reflect the
devaluation of of our dollar that has
taken place over the last couple of
decades representative
priest thank you Mr chairman for taking
my question and thank you for being here
and uh addressing this problem um my
question is how were the figures that's
in this bill
um how how are they come how did they
come about did you um get some Financial
experts to try to to bring them up to
the a reasonable standard I'm just
curious no no Financial experts no I I
relied upon the information they
received over wage and means regarding
what the uh U minimum uh wages and the
the uh um demographic data that is
provided to us regarding uh minimum
incomes and then I looked at an average
of an individual who's making uh single
individual are receiving Medicare it's
going to be somewhere around $2,000
19900 uh I don't think anyone really
makes 15 anymore after the recent
increases it's going to be around 19 to
22 so I just essentially doubled it from
that go ahead represent thank you for
letting me speak um did you uh ask the
town of Hudson to kind of give you a
kind of fiscal impact of what this would
do to their
revenue no but I did put a a revenue cap
in there uh on a single on Prop property
if you take a look at
the uh page whatever it is two down at
the bottom it says no event shall the
relief Grant to be greater than 10,000
or less than
five in order to do that I did not re
request information from the town of
Hudson
because this would be applied not just
to Hudson but to the entire State and
that's what we have LBA for or
Dr further questions representative
Brown thank you Mr chairman and thank
you for taking my question so the
question I have is that uh a lot of
people have different assets up here in
section 1A U different assets including
stocks and bonds and everything like
that that uh that people depend on to
draw on we'll say through interest that
type of thing for their livelihood why
was that exempt from the total
assets for exactly the reasons that you
just stated they draw upon it in order
to
live up go ahead so if I had $3 million
in assets and I was drawing on those
interests
um to support myself that's okay so
there's no limit on that I wouldn't U
place the limit on on that because $3
million in today's environment will
probably last you just a few
years thank
you representative
Guthrie thank you Mr chairman thank you
for the work I also have the white hair
and Paul category in fact I I'm I'm I'm
one of those border line ones uh that uh
can't quite qualify but we're we're
changing our parameters to a maximum of
$70,000 for for uh married couple so
it's going to be a lot easier for me to
qu qualify if I can but I have a
question on uh page two uh line 31 and
32 section section 4 what what does that
mean and why is that necessary to be in
this
bill because you could wind up uh from
some of the fears that uh representative
Brown was alluding to with an individual
who has a a great deal of uh uh residual
income that has gained over the years uh
from this would limit the liability of
the
community um and that was the reason it
was put in so it would be no greater
than 10 nor less than five so someone
would have a base of five that they
would get and uh take my community for
example uh the tax rate runs 6 to8 uh
roughly
68 something like that gu Hudson's
behind me but
uh so this is to Pro uh protect the town
somewhat from if somebody owns a big a
large home still qualifies for the
money's area even though they have the
extra money so they got a relief but
they're they're not going to pay any
more
than uh was it $10,000 in their tax
relief so if they get a tax bill of say
12,000 they only would get 10,000 relief
that that that would be correct sir I
might usually at the other
end my property's worth about 140,000 so
so well you're your m is a town property
a little bit more than that yeah so
thank you anyway thank you for your
effort thank you Mr
chairman thank you representative frct
thank you Mr chair and thank you for
taking my
question um as long as the proverbial
hood is up on this RSA and we're
tinkering with it I have two questions
um on Roman numeral
2A um the requirement is for residency
in the
state and what is the logic for state
residency versus the
municipality which is being applied to
for the
exemption I'm not exactly sure on that
Sirah because if you'll not all I did
was change the number of years in
existing
law right I I do I do understand that
and then what I did was let's make it a
long-term resident rather than a
short-term resident who may be engaged
in property
flipping okay uh followup Mr chair go
ahead uh my second question um Roman
3D uh again thew logic behind the uh
applicant being married for five years
okay hold on hold on hold on
representative um again a reminder to
everybody on the committee only
the uh
bolded type is what's being changed the
3D there's no change
there
so I don't really think there's we need
to get go down that road is existing
it's it's existing language not not not
being
amended further questions representa
priest thank you Mr chairman uh and
question how many communities are
currently using this exemption in their
uh local governments it would be up to
each Community to adopt it and I'm not
sure how many have adopted it or not I
know that mine has and and it is used Mr
chairman followup go ahead how many
households or indiv elderly individuals
do you know are currently using this
exemption I'm not aware of that number
okay thank you and followup Mr chair no
you don't ask questions well can I
continue to answer that one you may
answer if you you've got more
information thank you thank
you the specifics of individual ual
household incomes are not priv are
privileged under Dr regulation I could
get a WR round number but it would be an
uh uh an
in uninformative number because it would
include uh too broad of a scale so it'
be a number but it's
useless further
questions represent Gilman thank you Mr
chair and thank you thank you for taking
my question U my question's kind of uh
procedural I guess um this is
a an amendment to 7239 B but 7239 a
references this uh using the same
numbers that you want to change so my
question is um shall we work on an
amendment check with uh legislative
services wrote it they picked out which
ones belong where okay thank
you and that may in fact be an issue but
it's uh it's one that I think that's
more of an edit a mistake rather than
a sending it to the wrong place uh
further
questions seeing none I have one
representative um as we increase the
amount of uh exemptions for one group of
people in town is it am I correct in
assuming any loss revenue from those
Source will be redistributed and pulled
from the rest of the individuals in town
all that would generally be the form and
that's exactly what happens under the
current law that uh others are taking
care of those uh in town with uh less um
um means of uh accomplishing
uh life goals uh
however it's also incumbent upon the
community to make changes and to mon uh
moderate their own
operations to allow individuals who
reside in their Community to continue to
reside in their
homes okay thank you further
questions I see none thank you for your
testimony next up we will call
all uh Scott
Bartlet I will remind those who are
going to testify please when you uh
introduce yourself also State whether
you're for or against we know up here
from your cards but the rest of the
individuals do
not thank you uh Mr chair and members of
the committee allowing me to testify um
my name is Scott Bartlett I am the
assessor of the town of gtown um I do
oppose this bill as it is currently
written and my select board has
authorized me to speak to you today in
opposition to this uh bill again as
currently written um the the main issues
that we are opposed to are
um the net Asset definition and the the
range of the $5,000 to $10,000 um
minimum relief start with the assets um
on line line five of page of page one it
redefines
assets uh to not include investment
funds not being cashed in or withdrawn
except that any I'm not going to read
the whole thing but essentially what
this is doing is saying that investment
funds are no longer considered to be
assets and I think representative Brown
kind of touched on this you could have
millions of dollars of assets but still
qualify for the exemption I don't think
that's the intent of the elderly
exemption by redefining this in this way
it also creates uh what I consider to be
an very inequitable situation depending
upon what type of retirement plan an
individual has um just last week I had
an in a couple come in we are currently
at the maximum of
$60,000 um of income same as this this
bill would do so we have no objection to
that
change but essentially this couple came
in and their retirement plan was Social
Security and a pension they had limited
investment funds they made
$62,000 they did not
qualify but if this change were to be
made to the definition of assets you
could have an individual who has again
millions of dollars in Assets in in
investment funds they could take2 to
$300,000 a year out of those investment
funds but they would qualify into this
definition that does not seem to be
Equitable and you know we do have an
objection to that the other issue that
we have a objection to is
the just going to again find the line
it's line 31 to 32 on page
two this says in no event shall the
amount of relief granted be greater than
$10,000 or less than $5,000
well right now our maximum relief for a
um for an elderly over the age of 80 is
$2,600 so just this alone if we were to
make the minimum
$5,000 that would raise our tax rate in
town by 13 cents per thousand again that
doesn't seem like a lot but it is an
increase that's just taking this into
consideration with 182 elderly that we
currently have if the definition of
assets also changes we are going to
increase that number how many I don't
know I can't give you an estimate of
that right now but I'm pretty sure we
will increase that
number the other issue I have with this
range of relief is that the elderly
exemption is an exemption it's a certain
amount off of the assessed value it is
not a credit so we're taking an
exemption and putting a what almost like
a credit amount on that it would be
extremely difficult
to to administer that way because we
don't know what the until we get the tax
rate from the Dr we don't know how much
that relief is going to be the exemption
is set beforehand it's part of our
filing our
ms1 but again for me to set that at
$5,000 it would mean I would have to
calculate after the tax rate is already
set I do have written testimony that I
will leave here for you I haven't
touched on everything um but those are
the main issues that we are opposed to
um and I would be open to any
questions thank you very much for your
time thank you for your testimony
representative priest go ahead thank you
for taking my question and thank you for
being here have you had a um I know this
is lot lot to ask you but have you taken
a moment to kind of calculate what kind
of a fiscal impact this if this bill was
passed it would have for the town of
gost toown and how high the other
property taxes would have to be brought
you know risen to
um to meet this
uh the deficit that would come from
these properties um really the only
thing I did on that was at the the
minimum to the maximum the $5,000 to
$10,000 as I said that would have a 13 C
per th000 impact on our tax rate it
would increase our tax rate by 13 cents
the other parts of this again it all
would depend on how many more people
would qualify because of these
definitions um the income limit is not
an issue we are currently at 60,000 for
a married couple 42,500 for single the
asset limit would matter a little bit
because we are currently at
180,000 um but again I don't think those
are really the main issues we have if if
it went to 350,000 and that was the will
of the the legislature we would abide by
that the real issue is that new
definition of assets that's where we
have major opposition
to do you have a follow-up br
yes uh but you also have an issue with
um the amount of relief
granted of5 to 10,000 that is correct
okay thank you representative
Guthrie thank you Scott for coming and
testifying uh I I I have a in in my town
There's been about three times there's
been an article on a warrant to forgive
all taxes anybody over 85 I think they
took on the basis that they've paid
their dues over their life span and they
shouldn't be taxed when they get to be
85 whatever or whatever uh age do you
think that that that's the rationale
when this bill was set up that the
rationale was anybody in these in these
categories should be forgiven their
taxes because of the reason would be uh
that they are entitled because of the
number of years to pay tax okay um thank
you for the question um if that's the
rationale of this bill it would not it
does not do that because like I said the
couple I had last week who earned
$62,000 under this bill they would still
not qualify because they're over the
income limit
okay I understand so there are the
parameters don't produce the
the the question of anybody getting
everybody getting their tax
relieved at a particular age no matter
how much they would
make under this bill I I agree with what
you just said yes yeah thank
you thank you thank you for taking the
question
um if under the the logic of this bill
uh what you kind of alluded to no uh no
event shall the amount of relief be
granted less than $5,000 so if the a
person's tax bill was only
$4,500 the town would not be able to
grant them relief because it wasn't at
least $5,000 and the law says that no
relief granted shall be less than
$5,000 um thank you for the question um
I I'll be honest I'm a little confused
by the language here because if you do
have someone who whose taxes are
$4,000 does that mean that the town
would then have to pay them
$1,000 I'm not I'm unsure of that that
is one of the questions I raised in my
my written testimony I really wasn't
going to get into that but thank you for
bringing that
up further
questions seeing none I have one quick
one for you do you um monitor um the
total percent tax impact on
non um exemption claimers in your town
for I'm going to give you an example in
my town of barington I went to
my Town Administrator and
said if no exe exemptions
existed how far would the taxpayers
bills go down the other taxpayers who do
not pay claim any exemptions and I
believe at that time it was about a year
ago was about a five and a half perc
decrease in the overall tax do you track
that I have that information I did I've
never put it in a percentage like that I
can tell you just from the numbers that
I have on my written
testimony um if the if there was no
elderly exemption the tax rate would
probably be about 10 to 12 cents Le less
than it currently is just on that one I
was looking okay thank you very much
would you be able to run uh send in that
number by chance if you looked at all of
I'd just like to compare it between
barington and you said you were go down
yes so you're looking for the percentage
of all exemptions and credits yeah I
would just like to if you have that
handy don't I mean don't go through it
yeah that that information is right on
the ms1 okay it's very easy to to get
that information so I'd be glad to send
that in I'd love it thank you further
questions okay uh seeing no more for you
uh uh next up we have Jim mishel thank
you very much thank
you Mr chair may I pass out my testimony
what I let us sit here
okay
good morning Mr chair and members of the
committee my name is Jim Misha I'm the
chief assessor for the town of Hudson I
have not registered uh in favor or
opposed to this bill because the Hudson
Board of selectman have not directly uh
issued a uh an opinion on this bill so
I'm here mostly talking about the
administrative part there are some
policy Parts as well um this is a really
important tax exemption program in the
state um we uh annually are are in this
process of people applying um our
assessment review process with the
Department Revenue they monitor how we
Grant exemptions not just the elderly
exemption um and it's been a really long
time since these amounts were looked
that it was in the 1995 1996 General
Court under house bill
331 um it took two legislative years and
a study committee um to arrive at the
language that you pretty much see in in
the law today um in 2022 according to
the Dr there was $1.1 billion dollar in
elderly exemption value that's been
Exempted um and that would be $5,000 in
Exempted taxable value in Su all the way
up to 145.5 million in Exempted value in
Nashua um in terms of tax dollars it's
about $28.6 million in property tax
redistribution so it's it's Revenue
neutral right so the tax rate goes up to
account for Less taxable
value I do have attached a series of
concerns about the bill um number one on
my page three um has been addressed it's
most likely an OS uh item um lines
number two lines four through S talks
about investment funds uh that been
discussed prior um currently what we uh
don't count as an asset is the house
right so a person's actual residence up
to two acres or the Zone minimum is
Exempted we cannot count that as an
asset um not allowing the community to
count investment funds as an asset is a
rather significant expansion in assets
that would not be counted um so you know
one would imagine that we'd have more
people qualifying which is the intent of
the bill but there's also an impact to
that right um and also in terms of
investment funds it's not defined you
know we might want to Define what an
investment fund is there's 234 communi
we might have 235 different ways of
deciding what an investment fund is if
we don't have some
direction uh M number three again on
lines 4 through 7 um says that required
minimum distributions shall be uh
classed as an
asset um currently the IRS counts that
as ordinary income currently our
communities count that as income it's
money coming in from a required minimum
distribution um I don't know what it is
is if it's it is income you know calling
it asset is I don't know is is
misclassifying in my
opinion beyond that on my page four um
lines 20 through 21 this speaks to The
Residency requirement to change from
three years of state of residency within
the state to five it actually used to be
five years uh Senator Jack Barnes I want
to say a long time ago probably about 15
years ago um had it changed from 5 to
three
um the legislature agreed with that um
it's kind of problematic if this passes
right because I have some folks that
were here for three years right for this
year then this passes then next year
they'll only have been here for four
years so I guess we removed their
exemption or there's a Cil added to the
bill I'm not sure
um SEC uh my uh section my number five
uh under no circumstances and the
changeing the income amounts from 30,000
for single to 60,000 per married um the
significant increase right in the in the
minimums about over 200% increase in
both categories um all in one year um so
there's no there's no Glide path on it
right and other bits of legislation
we've had Glide paths and how the
minimums are going to be increased um
also we want to be sensitive to the
demographic uh economics of the state um
so the per capita income just on County
Alone um for for bellnap I'm sorry for
Coos County is
3,829 and in Rockingham it's 51,6 127 so
we're establishing higher minimums but
the state really has really far
different per capita incomes and medium
family incomes um and I'm not sure how
we address that right we have a state
law applies to every Community um but I
think you just want to be sensitive to
the the money made in Portsmouth is a
little bit different than the money made
in
Pittsburgh according to the Dr um the
medium income amount currently across
the whole state is 25,000 for
single um and for married the median
income amount and this is all of the um
all of the exemption amounts that have
been adopted within each Community uh
that Min median income amount is
36,000 just to put in in perspective 59%
of the communities are under 30,000 and
92% of the communities are under 60,000
so this would change things in those
communities um my number six um this
deals with life insurance on the death
this is lines 28 through 29 in the bill
sorry um life insurance paid on the
death of an insured is currently um
Exempted as an asset um that's been in
place for decades um this would now have
the community count that as as an asset
so um that's kind of going this way and
it's going this way a little bit in the
bill um lines 28 on page one and lines 1
through two on page two um says we are
to uh exclude revenue from investment
funds redeemed in any given year um
again currently we we count that as
income um and and that would have that
would have an impact upon the
community section8 my section eight my
page six lines seven through eight um
changes the asset amount from
35,000 to
350,000 or the median residential
property value in the
community again looking at some
statistics from the Dr currently 256
communities are under 350,000 in asset
limit just just a few just three are
over
350,000 um so it' be probably
significant change uh in Hudson as well
in Hudson our Exempted asset limit is
160,000
um still staying with that same section
it says median residential property
value whichever is lower we should
Define what is median residential
property value is it just single family
Does it include accessory living units
Does it include mixed use property um
small multifamilies you know we want to
make sure if we're going to administer
it we all administer it the same way um
and does it get arrived at annually only
after a reevaluation some other cycle um
who determines the value is it is it the
governing body the legislative body is
it subject to Amendment amendment by
attendees at a deliberative session is
the determination
appealable um and lastly and I'll finish
up lines 31 through 32 says in no event
shall the amount of relief granted be
greater than 10 or less than five we
would not know that until the tax bills
were already arrived at so we would and
I don't so we couldn't do it before the
bills went out and we couldn't do it as
a as an abatement legally after the
bills come out so that kind of doesn't
work within the property tax
administration within the
state um beyond that um I think I said
it was Revenue neutral um and in Hudson
um we are twice now last year we
increased our uh income amount uh as
well as our the amount of our exemptions
this year we're increasing the income
amount again and the amount of the
Exempted value per category um so
Community has the ability to do that
right they can raise the amounts um if
the voters approve it um in Hudson we
have about 179 properties that receive
the ELD of the exemption it is about 2
and a half cents on the tax rate so
every Community is going to be different
um but in Hudson um the the median I
should say the the amount of taxes
Exempted are between 2100 and 3600
currently right between the first age
level category up to the maximum age
category
um is a mandatory exemption every
Community has this right at the minimums
at minimum so um they can expand it they
just can't go lower than what's
currently there um at Hudson it takes
about 12 a half million in Exempted
value to change the tax rate by a penny
we have a little less than 30 million in
Exempted uh elderly exemption
value threw a lot at you there's more in
there and I'll take any questions thank
you very much for Testimony uh
representative Brown thank you Mr
chairman so towards the end there Mr
Mishu thank you for taking my question
uh you do a very very thorough job on
these bills when you come in thank you
for that so my question is you seem to
indicate that you have the ability to
legally do these things already in the
town of Hudson to increase the
exemptions and can you explain how that
works without the law being changed
thank you sure um so um we can't change
how what's considered an asset right
that's this does that right but we can
change through Warren article right
we're a town SP2 um so Warr article
either goes on because the Bor of
selectman offer it or the Warr article
Goes On by petition and they say we want
to raise or lower it's always raise
raise the amount of the income allowed
raise the amount of assets allowed raise
the amount of exemption allowed which is
not in here um and under the the current
law you know those also have not been
adjusted for a very long time the
minimum EX exemption amount so so that
and in cities it's different obviously
Town Council communities uh Charter form
of government um but the voters vote on
it or our representatives vote on it
such as
alderan thank you very
much representative
yella thank you um just to
clarify the
the impetus for this bill is that there
needed to be some inflationary change as
far as the minimum um but it seems to me
that your testimony says that the the
communities are already empowered to do
those changes as they see fit um in the
law as it stands and so no actual change
is needed to allow them to do that in
inflationary adjustment if they so
choose that's correct they can currently
do it thank
you further
questions seeing none thank you very
much thank
you all right I have one more pin card
Katherine heck in
HMA thank
you good morning Mr chairman and members
of the committee for the record my name
is Katherine heck representing the New
Hampshire Municipal Association and I
think you've heard from some of our
assessing experts some of the technical
concerns that exist within the bill um
Not only would it change the law and
create a mandate for cities and towns
that already can increase the exemption
and the income limits but there also is
a mixing of exemption versus credit um
within the law and we've been here many
times testimony testifying on how we
either need to have an exemption or a
credit but we certainly can't mix the
two together one happens before the tax
rate is set on April 1st when we show
our taxable inventory
and one happens after the tax rate is
set in December I did want to point out
just for interest the wide variety how
each town in New Hampshire might be
addressing this situation when they see
fiscal stress in their Community
especially around their elderly
populations on how they might be
addressing this locally for example um
the city of Lebanon has um a single
income limit of
45,000 and a married income asset limit
of of 100,000 the city of Manchester has
a single income limit of 41,000 and a
married asset limit of
13,000 molten Boro as another example
has a single income limit of 25,000 and
a married asset limit of 100 but then we
go to Northampton where they have a
married a single income limit hold on
let me just make sure I'm of four
$40,800 but a married income asset limit
of
$190,000 and then we'll go go to
Portsmith for another example just to
highlight the wide variety to address
this where a single income limit in
Portsmith is
46,2 and the married income limit and
the single asset limit are both half a
million so each Community for itself is
deciding how best to address this you'll
also see the exemption itself being
wildly varied in the amount that will be
reduced off the assessed valuation of
the property for example with Hudson
offering 80 plus individuals
$240,000 off their assessment molten
Boro 100,000 off Northampton 200
Portsmouth 335,000 um and NASA 280,000
so again each Community for itself and
these reports are right available on the
Dr website we can give you the links
show what each Community has decided to
adopt locally to address the elderly
exemption in their community using the
minimums and current law as The
Benchmark and increasing as they um see
appropriate for their community so I'll
certainly take any
questions represent
priest thank you Mr chairman for taking
my
question you didn't state if if the
municipal Association was in support or
opposed to this thank you we are opposed
to this legislation it would create a a
mandate I apologize thank you uh uh
follow please uh and in your estimation
uh with this bill um regarding the net
asset changes as well as the uh the
amount of relief
granted what impact would you H see in
these communities so again we haven't
worked up a study to examine that
carefully but generally when we expand
definitions and we expand the exemptions
or credits we will see the taxes
redistributed to
other every other taxpayer in the
community whether it's commercial or
residential but we will also see it um
change the disabled the deaf the Blind
and the veterans tax credits right
because everything gets redistribute
into the pi so if you change one and you
don't look at the other exemptions and
credits you could be disproportionately
impacting another vulnerable Community
member representative Yella thank you um
so this creates a mandate on the towns
to have at least um 30,000 for an
individual in your research did you find
any towns that this would bar their
current um
chosen uh relief yes I believe sorry oh
I I believe Jim um Misha from Hudson
might have provided you some of those
statistics and they'll be in his
testimony further
questions seeing none thank you very
much for your testimonies I have no more
pink
cards uh the blue signin sheet had
nobody signing in for or against so with
that we will close the public hearing on
HB
1106 and once the clerk is ready we will
proceed to the next
one
okay
uh where representative
oler are are you leaving
us we do we have the next
one yes represent could we see the
written testimony from the assessors
from gtown and they'll pass it around
great thank
you
okay we'll go ahead and open up the uh
hearing on HB
1284 relative to quasi judicial
authority of planning
boards and representative erery you are
up again thank you Mr chair for the
record my name is Jordan represent
priest um for the record my name is
Jordan ol rep uh Hillsboro
13 we go and uh I am on the planning
board in Hudson and that is the emphasis
this I had did have some input from the
uh uh Municipal Association regarding it
uh they actually called and uh discussed
it this bill I don't know why they
didn't call and discuss the other bill
but yeah that's them at any
rate
uh the impetus of this is some
individuals around the state in various
boards tend to forget that when they're
acting as a member of the planning board
they're acting as a member of a board
and they're acting in a uh quasi
judicial manner on most of the actions
that they
have even when the mandated
um master plan is being discussed
they're still receiving information from
the public and they need to judge that
in a quasi judicial manner as opposed to
uh a partisan
manner
uh
so the details of it are based upon
experience
and I'm hoping that the uh committee
will bring some clarity Statewide to the
operation of planning boards and I'll be
happy to
answer any questions okay thank you uh
representative
El thank you Mr
chairman good morning representative
oery we've known each other for a very
very long time and I want to thank you
for bringing um this bill
um I couldn't have said it better myself
and you've saved me a lot of time and
effort for next go
round um regarding the term quasi
judicial and
administrative are you in um line three
page
one establishing that the planning board
is a quasi judicial
administrative agency and if
so what does that
mean uh thank you for your
question yes and it means that it is a
quasi judicial body which is the way
that the uh Municipal Association in
their handbook for planning boards
defines the activities of the planning
board all this does is take what has
been a non-mandatory
uh
suggestion by the municipal Association
is to the operation of a planning board
and puts it into law so that the
planning boards know they have to take a
look at an applicant who's coming before
them with a site plan that they have to
take a look at it like this not from a
partisan
standpoint um unfortunately that that's
happened as uh the good representative
knows from personal experience
follow
up um under 673 colon 14
disqualification of
member uh Roman 1 it says that the board
is to
decide in a judicial
capacity um relative to Bing uh planning
boards and cbas building codes um
historic districts Etc so I'm just a
little
confused because I
don't
understand if this will somehow
change this well the number one the
planning board currently is not a
Judicial body that says in a Judicial
manner capacity correct right sorry all
this does is establish the ability for
the board itself to be established as a
quasi judicial body it doesn't fall
under the Judiciary statute it falls
under the administrative statute but
it's operating in the quas judicial
banner and the same way the DMV in their
civil actions operates in a quasa
Judicial manner thank you very
much representative priest thank you for
taking my question and thank you for
being here uh having served planning
boards for 45 years in in my past life I
appreciate this effort of uh putting in
what we should be doing on the planning
boards and where sometimes not is this a
problem um in Hudson now or other
communities I'm not going to speak for
Hudson because if you're a member of the
planning board you have no standing as
an
individual having experience with Hudson
and other
communities
occasionally individuals forget that
they're part of a board and think that a
decision can be made on their own behalf
this has happened not only with the
planning board or with the Zoning Board
of a um I forget the name of zoning
board or even select boards where
individuals have acted on their own be
behal as opposed to the fact that
they're a member of the board and so
what this does does is create a
Statewide standard for the planning
board that comports with existing
recommendations by the municipal
Association under best
practices um it also provides some
um information regarding um the
presentation of uh information that may
or may not be misleading uh when a
person is making a representation to the
board and that's you know that's
something we have to deal with here uh
in our own committees at times where
perhaps the information related is not
necessarily as um accurate as could have
been provided why did I walk around that
enough representative
yulla thank you on page four um lines 6
through
14 um it talks about how if an applicant
um can request the recusal of a specific
board member and that the board shall
immediately suspend further hearings on
the matter immediately before the
board um and essentially uh you know
schedule a new public hearing and
address the that isue but um isn't uh
some of
the requirements of planning boards that
they um continue or or decide on certain
issues in a certain matter of time based
on statute and so
if they were required by law to figure
out something in let's say 60 days and
this is the 60th day and they got a
an a request for recusal at the
beginning of that meeting would now they
be in non-compliance with another
statute if they followed your statute
and and vice versa no I call your
attention lines 12 and 13 uh a delay to
the hearing to hear the recusal request
shall stay the determinate determination
time schedule for the board to uh render
a
decision
delay to hear the recusal shall stay the
time
schedule for the board to render a
decision on the delay on the on the
request for a recusal or for the the
subd develop the development that
they're currently trying to decide on
when they got the the language was
designed to cover the The Proposal that
was so that the time schedule the 60-day
calendar is stayed when a request for
recusal is made so that the an
obligation is not so it would be done
frivolously but that it would stay it
until a decision is made so when the
decision is made come when the board
comes back and and and has a decision on
or a hearing actually on the request for
recusal
then the the clock would start after
that time frame
represent FR I saw your hand up yes
thank you Mr chair I promise this time I
will confine my question to bolded items
only um on page
one um looking at lines 13 and
14 I wondering if you could give us some
examples of when a board
May
[Music]
um require uh information under oath as
opposed to
shall depends on the proposal coming
before them uh let's
uh let's say that a particular developer
has a um known
history I would think it would be best
business practice for a uh uh quasi
judicial body to require uh indiv like a
loyalist individual uh to use a broad
very very very very broad
comparison uh that that individual
provide testimony under oath uh then
maybe some individual on the board uh
has an issue with one person While
others do not this may be a method for
them to take that or it could be
stricken and it could be said that any
uh written uh information provent uh
provided is done under unsworn um
falsification uh that's you know that's
that's up to the this committee uh the
way it goes thank you for answering my
question yes sir representative
El oh me okay thank you thank you Mr
chairman I'm looking at page
four Romans
[Music]
7 where the applicant May request the
recusal of a specific board member for
cause then I'm looking at Roman
8 oh I'm
sorry
nine
where if a board member has an interest
direct interest in a parcel
underdevelopment the member must
disqualify themselves from the
discussion what is the difference
between recusal and
disqualification recusal would be
refraining from engaging in the
discussion at the time where a
disqualification says you were
one is a voluntary activity and the
other is a mandatory Activity thank you
follow up Mr chair thank
you
um under Roman 9ine line
22 if a board member has a direct
interest this is under conflict of
interest
disqualifications if a board member has
a direct interest in a parcel
underdevelopment I've seen the
uh uh the
term interest in the
outcome in uh other like zoning board
rules I think for
disqualification um and I wonder
if direct interest is too vague does it
need to be
defined I would say no because that
that's a term of art direct interest
means that you have a monetary um
interest in the uh the project you have
a direct interest in interest is mod is
in my world downstairs that means you
have a monetary interest or uh um
benefit being derived from that
particular project
clarification uh followup go ahead thank
you
um so in other statute it says um
personal or pecuniary interest is that
the same thing uh no because you have
two different things a personal interest
would be let's say uh a personal
interest would be um maintaining a
wooded lot because you have a nice view
of a forest as opposed to pecuniary Ines
which means developing that lot would
give you a sizable
paycheck okay thank you
s Gilman thank you Mr chair and thank
you for taking my question um this is
very clear to me U what your intentions
are I was just wondering if um what you
have added is really what you recommend
to the rules of procedure for planning
board I'm so I'm I'm wondering if what
you're suggesting and the new things of
what you know outlining what a planning
board needs to consider in their
application are really the things um
that you're recommending be put in the
um set of rules of procedures when you
require that I'm just trying to simplify
how the board's goingon to if the
board's going to change or I the board
shouldn't change that much uh those
boards that are following the guidelines
set up by the new New Hampshire
Municipal Association are pretty much
doing this to begin with I know that
Hudson adopted uh a set of um bylaws for
operation
recommend um that was recommended by the
municipal Association and was also
recommended uh by some of the testimony
that we'd heard downstairs and uh Ways
and Means from U various entities uh
which sets up some some uh pretty good
like guidelines representative Pierce
priest excuse me um I don't know about
you the community year over and over you
said I don't know how they do it over
there uh I don't know if you have your
own bylaws but I do know that there are
some communities that quite literally
make it up as they go
along thank you represent yella thank
you thank you for taking the question
um as a zba board member um I am aware
that there is a vote that can be had um
about whether or not we they recommend
someone uh ref refrain from a perfect a
particular hearing but there is nothing
that is binding on that uh vote
and
I am not sure if this um like whole of
page four um is meant to be binding
because it does not say that the board
member um shall then recuse himself or
may recuse himself or do anything it
just that the board other than that
member will take a vote um and so can
you expound on what your intention is
and how maybe that may be in Conflict if
it is with how zba is currently uh
work well U since this doesn't deal with
the zba it deals with the planning board
no but at the same time
yes I've been to to court too many times
um if you take a look at section
four the the members of the plan board
sh so it does apply to
them in one instance of which I am
familiar a member of the select
board while sitting as a member of the
planning
board called a
developer uh a variety of
names um
so it's not limited to the the uh
members of the planning board you can't
have that if you're going to have an
unbiased decision so you have to
disassociate yourself if you will from
your personal opinions and evaluate each
plan separately based upon the facts in
front of you and that's what the intent
of this bill is is to set this down a
set of rules that applies now you want
to change one or two or three or four or
a paragraph perfectly fine but the idea
is to make sure the planning boards
boards in general you start with the
planning board and then it'll trickle
down to the other boards behave in a
fashion that doesn't denigrate
applicants it doesn't denigrate members
of the board it provides everyone with
an equal
access you know big phrases here equal
access and judgment under the law yeah
but
that's that's the intent because
unfortunately representative priest
thank you Mr chairman for taking my
question and thank you uh I have a
question regarding page four Section 8
abutters in any project or development
being heard can request the accusal or
disqualification of a
specific uh board member uh to me I see
this as a delay tactic that um nimes can
um use to basically kill a project
because as we know time is money to
developers of projects and um no one
wants change in their communities and no
one wants uh anyone else to move in
there so can you talk about that further
thank you sure glad to having been the
subject of
that you may recall that there was a uh
small project that was designed that was
uh offered Hudson couple of years ago uh
the abutters accused me of being biased
because I happen to be a member of Alec
it turns out that the developer he'll um
I forget the name of it Hills something
from the other construction company and
Amazon um were objectively not part of
uh Alec and that was the decision that
those particular corporations had made
when when they were offered to join
which is perfectly fine I mean it's
immaterial um the alleged bias that was
an attempt as the good representative
pointed out on in my belief uh to delay
the project
however a property and a butter to a
property under development should have
every right to use
every available thing to get their point
of view across regarding it so you allow
them the opportunity denying them the
opportunity is a
mistake it's a mistake because it denies
them the chance to say what's going to
happen now in a particular development
turned out one of the property owners
decided to sell because he knew his
property value was going to go down and
he got almost
$300,000 more than the assessed value of
his house so that particular argument
disappeared
but that's neither here nor
there further
questions uh represent
power thank you Mr chair and thank you
for taking my question with regards to
that same section on page four Roman
numeral
7 is there do you have any concerns with
regards to rec recusal of board members
and then the inability of there might
not be enough um like substitutes to to
the planning board the the alternates
and then then what would
happen because some the meeting would
come to an end
okay until the next
meeting and and you could make sure that
you have uh but because you wouldn't
have a
quorum your Quorum doesn't necessarily
if you got say seven permanent members
and three alternates you you know would
your Quorum is what five
so getting five out of 10 people is
going to
be you know it you could happen but you
know meteorites could hit too all right
I don't mean to make light of it because
it it is a good point representing power
I appreciate it better
questions seeing none I have a single
question for you
representative are planning boards
currently considered in your opinion uh
quasi judicial administrative agency as
I indicated only by Best Practices
administered or suggested by the the
municipal
Association um in my discussions with
them they suggested that this would be a
good idea to make sure that that is put
into law because that creates them into
a status that obligates a certain type
of
behavior in dealing with the
public correct but they are even though
it's not I just I just want to make 100%
clear currently planning boards operate
as a quasi judicial administrative
agency under best practices not okay all
right thank you further
questions seeing none
did yes Mr chair I I would like to
expound on your that will be in the
executive session okay yep thank you
okay all right thank you representative
have any more the blue sheet there were
nobody signed in on the blue sheet I
have no more pink cards nobody here for
or
against so thank you very much we'll
close the hearing on HB 1284 and believe
it or not we are on time uh 11 o'clock
will be our next uh
start
absolutely my
pleasure
folks please take your
seats
okay we're going to go ahead and open up
the public hearing on HB
1187 that is relative to local
legislative bodies voting threshold for
approval of Le agreements over 100,000 I
see the prime sponsor sitting there
representative power you have the
floor thank you Mr chairman and
honorable committee members as the prime
sponsor I appreciate the opportunity to
introduce to you today House Bill
1187 for your consideration for the
record I am represent representative
Diane power I represent the towns of
Brookline Mason and Greenville in
Hillsboro County District
36 to begin Mr chair it's come to my
attention that across our state there is
widespread misuse of the statute
governing lease agreements of equipment
by some governing bodies under current
RSA school districts and towns are able
to place extremely high cost lease
agreements with 10 to even 20year ter
terms on the warrant needing and this
needs only a simple majority vote to be
approved if a
non-appropriation or Escape Clause is
included in the proposed lease agreement
moreover in school districts in towns
with a traditional town meeting a hand
card vote is all that is currently
required to pass such lease
agreements increasingly school districts
are using lease agreements with Escape
clauses clearly to avoid the 35ths
majority ballot vote when projects of
this ma magnitude and scope should
really be
bonded based on my own research to date
I have found 15 examples in counting of
school districts misusing lease
agreements of equipment with Escape
Clauses for example in my own District
in
2022 the Brookline School District put
forth a warrant article for an 18-year
lease agreement totaling 2.5 million for
energy conservation equipment an
elevator security improvements and room
Renovations and just this year in 2024
the Thornton school district is putting
forth a 20year lease for a boiler room
replacement costing $4.4
million and the the most egregious
misuse of this lease statute that I
found was in
2023 where the Timberlane Regional
School District placed on the warrant an
article to fund a 20year lease agreement
totaling
$25.2 million for facilities repairs and
maintenance and unbelievably in their
voters guide it explained that their
real facility repair needs total over
$116
million stop and think to yourself how
is a lease agreement with an escape
Clause practical in these applications
and how could you even escape a least
renovation of Greater concern is the
fact that school districts and towns are
taking advantage of a loophole in the
RSA by which they are appropriating
taxpayer dollars to fund major
facilities improvements and Renovations
around the lease of equipment Mr chair
this is a very serious problem that must
be addressed by the legislature which is
why I fit filed this bill in front of
you today the purpose of this bill is to
end the misuse of lease agreements of
equipment by changing the criteria and
the voting threshold for the legislative
body's approval of equipment leases over
$100,000 from a simple majority to a
35ths super majority ballot vote now I
will briefly explain how this bill
addresses the problem so I have passed
out an
amendment which is obviously an
amendment to the bill as filed I started
drafting this bill in the summer I
worked on it a long time and ever since
it um it was referred to this committee
I I've continued to go over it and
refine it and so the amendment in front
of you is is many edits because this is
an important bill and to be clear um
nhma has has looked at the the original
Bill language and so we've been talking
back and forth and I've put forward many
um refinements of this bill for their
you know feedback and at this point
right now for this bill hearing the
amendment that I pass passed out is is
the the version that I have right now I
am open to continuing to work with nhma
to further refine this as needed so I
will briefly talk about um the the the
highlights of of my Amendment so in
section one of the amended Bill
languages struck to close the loophole
that allows for building or facility
improvements related to the installation
of a piece of equipment to be deemed as
equipment which permits the cost of
those of the renovations to be financed
through a lease agreement that that's
that's significant that that's a huge um
change and very important this loophole
allows for building materials like
framing drywall flooring doors windows
electrical lighting HVAC Etc to be quote
unquote leased again how can these fixed
and installed building materials be
returned under an escape
clause further in um the amended version
of the bill under Roman numeral 3 the
amendment makes clear that building or
facility improvements related to the
installation purpose or operation of a
piece of equipment shall not be financed
through a lease agreement Roman numeral
4 ends long-term leases ofif 10 15 20
years by clearly limiting the term and
of an equipment lease to 7 years Roman
numeral six specifies um that a special
warrant article shall be used for lease
agreements and that these warrant
articles shall include a
delineated um dollar amount of the
Appropriations for each year of the
lease lease agreements up to $100,000
with an escape Clause shall require a
simple majority vote of the Le
legislative body to be approved and
Lease agreements exceeding $100,000
with an escape Clause shall require a
35ths super majority ballot vote of the
legislative body to be approved as with
bonds the polls at traditional uh
meetings will remain open for at least
one hour in subsequent years a lease uh
a special warrant article um shall be
placed on or may be placed on the
warrant to raise in appropriate funds to
continue the lease agreement and
subsequent years it will um only require
a majority vote of the legislative body
to be approved alternatively
Appropriations for continuing the lease
agreement may appear as an individual
line item in the approved operating
budget for this option no I I've
specified that no other purposes can be
co-mingled in with that uh individual
line item and importantly this
requirement provides a mechanism by
which the legislative body can non
appropriate the line item for the
lease and that is um that's allowed
under RSA 32 col 10 Roman numeral 1e the
lease agreement shall be terminated by
the governing body under the terms of
the Escape Clause if the special warrant
article to appropriate the funds to
continue the lease agreement is not
approved by the legislative body or if
the legislative body reduces the lease
budget line item to zero and if
sufficient funds for the lease agreement
are not available in a capital reserve
fund with the with the stated equipment
purpose Roman numeral 7 allows for lease
agreements to be funded through an
established capital reserve fund um as I
said with a um equipment purpose and
then next in section two of the
amendment um the bill adds lease
agreements to the definition of a
special warrant AR article um because
that they're multi-year expenditures and
finally in section three of the
amendment the bill the amendment
requires towns or school districts that
have adopted the enabling statute
requiring that the estimated tax impact
be printed on the warrant that um
multi-year leases the tax impact shall
be printed um as well if if um that
enabling statute has been adopted so in
summary House Bill 1187 is much needed
legislation that requires a 35th super
majority ballot vote to approve the
lease agreements over
$100,000 and this is important since
lease agreements commit significant
spending over multiple years this bill
limits the term of a lease agreement to
no more than seven years and most
importantly this bill closes a loophole
that allowed build or facility
improvements and Renovations related to
the
installation of equipment to be financed
through the lease agreement I
respectfully ask that you please
recommend recommend ought to pass as
amended on House Bill
1187 to bring an end to the misuse of
lease agreements of equipment thank you
Mr chairman that concludes my bill
introduction I'm happy to answer any
questions
representative
kill thank you Mr chair thank you for
taking my question um I'm a little
perplexed about some of your
testimony um op operated Steam Plant for
the US Army for Fortune 500 companies
all your testimony was that a school
leased boiler
equipment that is correct thank you for
the question representative that is
correct quick followup what what school
is
that so um as I said I've identified 15
school districts that that are engaging
in this this um use misuse of
um this um lease lease agreement of
equipment so
I I have many pages here off the top of
my head I I don't recall which one least
boiler equipment
um I think in fact there are a couple
I'm happy to um get back to
you represent
appr thank you for taking my question um
and thank you for being here and for
representing this bill um I'm confused
about the amendment that you presented
today and the bill are we just supposed
to kind of focus on the amendment
because it doesn't really relate to this
the as we have it thank you for the
question representative um the amendment
does relate to the bill as I explained
um it's represents a a a
refinement of the the bill a as filed
back in September
so you you have
to you have to look at how it how OS
drafted it I'm not sure that that
answered your question
represent
priest as a followup when you say that
15 communities missed
use um these lease
agreements um I I would like to have
some information about those 15 and and
the projects and the leases that pertain
to them thank you thank you
representative I have that information
here on several Pages um where you know
I I did my research and I pulled that
information um I'd be happy to to share
that with you for your
review yeah I would recommend sharing
that with everybody just so we all have
it representative Jo
Kell thank you thank you for taking the
question um it seems that the
$100,000
um is not
as not the you know expansive amount
that um the ones that you're that you
were talking about the abuses of
multi-million dollar contracts and stuff
like that so why did why did you focus
on the monetary issue and not just the
length of the and just stick with like
you know at least no more than seven
years and just stick with that instead
of having this additional layer of the
money issue also thank you rep
representative thank you for asking that
question so um I I did focus on the the
length of the term of the lease
agreement and and this bill um proposes
to cap that at seven like you identified
and the reason why I also address the
the the monetary number the
$100,000 is
because with in currently in statute
with with regard to lease agreements
there there that number
$100,000
um is specified if there is um no Escape
Clause so just to be consistent so we
don't have different numbers jumbling
around in statute that's why I chose
that that particular number um I'd be
open
to changes represent K thank thank you
Mr chair thank you for taking another
question on these uh these leases in in
your research and and searching this
those contracts that are
clearly abuses um did they include like
maintenance contracts for those pieces
of equipment too like what was their
benefit for M there's no benefit for so
my thank you for the question
representative so my my research that
I'm happy to share with you it's it's in
a very rough form right here and maybe
not um
digestible and I did not have the time
to put it in in a nice format like I
would like to so what I did is I I
researched Warren articles and so I I
have I
have the reference where a warrant
article was was put on you know the
warrant in these different school
districts and so I've also um cut the
actual warrant article the wording that
went on the warrant I did
not do additional research to to delve
into contracts and all all of that um
again I don't H have much success with
the research Department here so I needed
I had to do this all on my own um and
also I would like to state that um in my
um Bill introduction I did say that it
was the Timberland I mean the Thornton
School District was one example of um a
school district that used a lease
agreement with an escape clause for a
boil a boiler room replacement I I saw
that on their
warrant representative majori thank you
Mr chairman and thank you representative
for taking my question my question it's
it's a two-part question if it's okay
with the chair but you'll tell me if
it's not uh and that's fine uh
representative I'm on page two between
lines 18 and 20 um it seems to me that
there's an expansion
in there of the intent of the original
bill which was for leases this includes
multi-year collective bargaining
agreements and so my question is why was
that added to the amendment but but also
to that you add in line the end of 19
and into 20 that the estimated tax
impact if it's a 7ye lease a town will
go through a reval in that period
because they'll have to do it every five
years do you have concern s that the tax
impact will not be accurate in year
potentially after even year one but
certainly after year five thank you okay
thank you for the two questions um so to
answer the first one on page two of the
amendment as you noted I um yes I I
added in those other um items because
they are multi-year um expend
to answer the second question you had
said that asked if I was concerned that
the tax impact will not be accurate and
my response to that would be that the
voters need to have the information at
that point in time that snapshot and
yeah I do recognize that it's not going
to be written in stone things will
change however the bill requires that in
order for the lease agreement to
continue There Will Be subsequent
um warrant articles to to address that
and then in the subsequent years then
that information would be updated just
it's just to inform the voters of the
long range what they're getting
into thank you and I apologize for
having my head down normally I'd be
respond or listening but I just have to
take
notes
forther questions representative Gilman
thank you Mr chair and thank you for
taking my rep my question um currently
uh towns
will purchase individual vehicles for
lease purchase uh for different
departments and it will come in their
tax or budget line for those different
purposes do you would you consider that
one lease because it's for
vehicles so me understand you thank you
for the question representative so
you're referring to my comments about
the um line item and not comingling
because often times towns municipalities
will will have a light line item for
lease for leases in
collectively so the question question
was if we are doing lease purchases for
individual
vehicles from and I will say from
different departments because that's
what we do um but would you consider
somebody could interpret uh that as
really one
least well that that would be under one
line
item the question would be is it
possible to break to break those out
into sub line items therefore each one
could be um accessed individually I I
think that that that's a
possibility representative
Las thank you Mr chairman and thank you
uh fellow Committee Member
um in our town
we
typically uh do lease purchase
agreements for for instance a fire truck
let's say a fir Tru of
$700,000 so in that case would that
require a super
majority to approve that thank you
representative um it depends I didn't
catch if you said if there's an escape
Clause are not but yes um if this bill
were to to become law then because that
is over $100,000 then then yes but I
would also like to note that you know
something like a fire truck that that
can be returned I mean that's not a
fixed permanent installed item so
um that's that's not what this bill you
know con is concerned with it's the
other um examples that that I cited
follow up Mr chairman go ahead so in
that case the in the case of the fire
Tru the Escape
Clause would be
valid could you
explain what the Escape Clause how how
the law looks at an escape
Clause thank you for the question
representative so um if I understand
your your question my my response would
be an escape clause and a lease
agreement enables or allows the the
items to the lease agreement to be
terminated and for the items to be
returned further details um that you may
be looking for would would be found in a
particular lease agreement what the
terms are which it's different for every
lease agreement
representative
kill thank you for taking my question
thank you Mr chair do you think it's
possible to return installed HVAC
equipment thank you for the question
representative I I I it m it it makes no
sense it's impractical but yeah I guess
you could rip everything out you know
break down walls it's it doesn't make
any sense
but representative
Holland thank you for taking my question
I hope this is makes sense how did you
pick a
$100,000 thank you for the question
representative I believe that that
question was already asked of me and and
my my response was is that um the
current statute RSA 33 colon 7 that
speaks to lease agreements of equipments
um that that's the whole statute that
we're dealing with and that it does
specify
um the the number $100,000 so instead of
picking some other random number and
potentially adding to confusion I just
um opted to be
consistent s
gallager um so regarding HVAC equipment
I mean we've got an A piece of HVAC
equipment that um air purifier right
over there in the corner don't we would
that count or are
you thank you for the question
representative I don't to me that's
that's a piece of portable equipment
that's an air purifier I'm not sure
what's exactly behind you in the corner
there
um clearly when I'm referring to HVAC
equipment I'm referring to f
installed you
know equipment related to heating
ventilation air
conditioning forther questions
represent thank you Mr chair and thank
you for taking my questions um would it
make any
sense
[Music]
to spell
out like
your HVAC system
or as
being I can't see a leas leasing company
doing this but evidently they have um so
that it's like limited to equipment that
can be returned if if it's not
funded uh is there some way
to kind of cut that out and spell it out
thank you for the question
representative I I do believe that I
have addressed that very sufficiently
and if you look in the look to the the
bill as um filed on page one lines 8
through 11 there's those lines that are
struck out that in fact
is in my estimation a loophole that
refers back to effect of lease contract
and that's under um section 382 and it
specifically says in general that lease
of goods that are fixtures um or that
become
fixtures of ordinary building materials
um you can't lease that but the problem
is is that in
this those lines are the loophole that
that allows that those types of things
to be leased so by striking that and
further in amended bill
um on page one section three it makes it
very clear that um these things shall
not be financed through um lease
agreements forther questions represent
Gilman thank you Mr chair and thank you
for taking another question um mine is a
followup to uh representative tet's uh
question about uh
equipment for in particular
HVAC
um you put you have put in here the
installation but there are uh an
operation but there are pieces of
equipment say for example
um uh what is it for hbac the um through
wall units that can be replaced if they
fail um when you do
um I can't remember yeah split many
splits thank you very much and the
condenser unit that sits outside that's
not built in and can be replaced
separately from uh you know what's in
the ceilings in the walls um so I'm I
I'm wondering if
this
um dampens the ability of maintaining an
HVAC C
system thank you for the question
representative I I don't share your your
opinion and your analysis um with
regards to the problem that I'm trying
to solve here I believe that you know
for the dollar amount of many splits
that might need to be replaced there's
other mechanisms to do that but that
being said um I I I continue to um and
will continue to work you know with nhma
to to to go over this
language um to refine it if necessary
and I am open to any um feedback from
this committee so that I could
incorporate that into um whatever goes
to the exact session thank
you further
questions seeing none I have one
representative
uh the amendment you passed out today um
as qu is quite a bit different than the
original Bill one of the things I note
is on the original Bill RSA 33 colon 8
was a major part of your bill and now
that is no longer part could you explain
why thank you for the question Mr chair
so um in speak I was approached by NH
with um regards to this this bill that's
coming up for the Ing and um the
feedback that that I got was um not to
be mixing or placing um what I'm trying
to do here with regards to to to this
bill to solve the problem that I've
clearly laid out it it's not really the
best approach to be um putting it in 338
with regards to bonds and and notes the
the recommendation was to Simply keep
that in 33 colon 7 under lease
agreements of equipment which I I I
agree and so that's why um
furthermore this the amended version
It's a repeal and replace because to try
to amend the bill as filed it would
would have been very confusing so to
make things very simple um and like I
said I've streamlined this I've worked
very hard on this to to keep refining it
this is the amendment represents what it
is where it is today
um that's the reason okay thank you
further
questions seeing none thank you for your
testimony uh Katherine heck welcome
again
good morning Mr chairman and members of
the committee for the record my name is
Katherine Heck from The New Hampshire
Municipal Association I serve as the
government Finance adviser for cities
and towns and in my capacity at nhma um
these are the types of things that we do
discuss often with cities and towns I
want to say that we have spoken with
representative power and we are always
looking forward to amendments and
improving legislation that will
basically have desired effect to solve
the issue at hand however I'm here today
to talk about the bill as written I
cannot speak on the amendment so with
that said I apologize in advance that
I'm not going to be able to speak on an
amendment I will only speak at the bill
as written and I'll just say that we do
oppose the bill as written because
there's there would be a significant
change to the current legal process
which is already defined in law for how
equipment leases and it would further
create some technical issues um around
the procedure for authorizing um
long-term debt so there is already a
prescription in law for a capital lease
which is one that's defined as the
transfer of ownership would occur at
some point in time under 30 RSA 338 for
anything over
$100,000 so we have two kinds of leases
we have Capital leases in which the
municipality or the political
subdivision or the school will take
ownership of that item and then we have
operating leases which the ownership St
days with the lessor meaning they will
always own it and they can take it back
at any time so the law already
contemplates this however I do want to
agree that striking lines 9 through 11
on page one under RSA
337e would alleviate the 2014 Law
changes that have created a great area
in the law that may be interpreted as
allowing for things like Windows Doors
and roofs to somehow be leased we know
we cannot take them back equipment
already has a legal definition and it
already exists so equipment and
Machinery there is a distinction between
property that's fungible within the law
and permanent fixtures so we know a
window is a permanent fixture we're not
debating that and again the law change
in 2014 has created some gray area so
well the issue the sponsor is trying to
solve there's nothing done illegally
because under the current law a building
or facility Improvement related reled to
equipment is allowed in law so nothing
was done illegally however it might not
be the purpose for which this was this
section was put in so we would agree by
simply striking this section of Law and
not touching any other parts of the
lease the sponsor's objective of
ensuring that basically bondable
projects that have long-term and Lasting
character meaning a huge facility
Improvement would go through the regular
Bond on process as they should and have
that 2/3 or 3- fifths majority vote as
already required in law but we do really
want to talk a little bit about RSA 337e
because this is really around leasing of
equipment equipment machinery right
there are situations um in which a
municipality because we operate on a
year-to-year budget schedule right we
know at the end of the year our monies
lapse if they are unspent we only can
spend up to the amount that was approved
for those purposes by the legislative
body and at the end of that year we
start over we start over with a new
budget process so leasing of equipment
under the RSA contemplates that we
already operate on that year-to-year
basis we can either have a minicipal
Escape clause and that would typically
be for an operating lease one in which
maybe we would be giving it back or we
could be having a capital lease where we
transfer ownership but either way we
already have to put that in front of of
the voters at some point in time and by
way of a warrant article and I've
provided some examples of the Dr
prescribed language um in either case
now if they're over $100,000 or more and
we know we want to keep that fir truck
it's an $800,000 fir Tru and we know we
want to keep it there's going to be no
Municipal Escape Clause we have no
intention of giving it back and that's
going to go through the bond process
right that's going to have to be
elevated onto the warrant as one of the
first warrant articles has to have an
hour of time for the public to vote I
mean a very prescribed process now if
we're maybe a big city and that's why
the $100,000 or the terms of s years or
any amount of years might be challenging
is we have a greater and I know a
community has I is doing some research
entered into a
10-year operating lease to have a
greater because that type of equipment
can last much longer some communities
will have Capital leases for fire trucks
because they're smaller and want to keep
it because they could probably use it
for 25 years a large city I don't know
that I'm not going to be an expert in
fire trucks or police cars but they have
a very different useful life depending
on their their use so by tying any type
of dollar amount to a lease it could be
cumbersome however the law already
requires the legislative body to approve
these expenditures whether they're in
with an escape clause or without and I
think we have to look at a
municipalities um what the intent is so
I did provide an example in my testimony
about an a real life example of a town
that had a major it um a fraud occur
around its it and they were severely
compromised now their hardware and
software were over 10 years old so no
company could come in and make that um
make those fixes that were necessary
they did an RFP they needed to address
it immediately again they were
compromised there was fraudulent
activity so a company came in and said
we'll do a three-year lease on or
fiveyear lease whatever the case may be
on it hardware and software upgrades now
gby Accounting Standards now allow us to
even lease software and why is that
because software gets better so even on
your Microsoft your personal Microsoft
remember you used to be able to buy it
and own it and now they kind of let you
buy it one year at a time now because
they're changing it so often so what
would a select board do in this terrible
situation that is a real world situation
they would enter into this lease they
would get hardware and software how long
do computers last not very long anymore
right they would get an escape Clause
they would bring it before the
legislative body in one of two ways
either they would ask for year-over-year
funding or they would ask for the
contract to be bought out and at the end
of the three-year term they want to be
able to give back return all of those
computers and get new ones so they're
never put in the situation again where
they don't have up-to-date equipment and
they would be highly compromised so
again the Dr Pur describes a language
that the number of years has to be
disclosed if there is a municipal Escape
Clause the amount the purpose and what's
to be raised in taxes so we know that
there is a lot of case law and addition
around lease and Lease agreements and
what is considered a fixture and all
that is included in my testimony but
again we know that real versus personal
property so based on the sponsors intent
in our conversations I I do believe by
striking the language in lines 9 through
11 and not going into any other areas of
the lease you can accomplish the goal of
ensuring that windows and roofs and
doors go through the bonding process and
anything that is real equipment that can
be taken back or returned or in fact
leased for some number of years and the
the company will come in and keep
replacing it like a copy machine for
example right they'll take it back or
repair and replace it and it's their
problem could also be addressed so we
certainly want to be sensitive to what
may be happening and how the sponsor
seeks to address it so I'm certainly
happy to take any questions I won't get
into all the the case law but I have
cited it for you and we are looking
forward toward a resolution um that
everyone can feel comfortable with thank
you very much for the testimony do we
have
questions representative
Brown thank you Mr chairman uh thank you
Miss heck for taking my question so um I
spent some time on the capital
Improvement Committee in in my town and
it it's kind of a fiveyear process that
we look at typically to determine what
these long-term leases might be um and
to address those but U from my
recollection I don't think there's any
legal requirement that those um items
that are placed in the capital plans are
followed or that they look at any legal
requirement such as what's put forward
in the in in this bill can you uh
clarify that I'm sure you're familiar
with that process thank you yeah so the
capital impovement planning process is a
planning board function um it works
along with the select boards that we
look at a six-year plan on what type of
equipment and facility needs we might
have in our future year so that we can
because our budget covers one year but
we know that we'll have to replace a
police car a fire truck a a dump truck
Windows Doors and roofs so that Capital
plan is certainly not contemplated in
this but the financial piece to your
Capital plan right but again that's all
voluntary would address that it would
address funding mechanisms and how you
plan to get from A to B to C to d right
so we know we need a police cruiser and
we need one every three years on a
replacement schedule we're going to
lease it we're going to give it back and
trade that one in every three years and
continue it on so that could be part of
your financial plan for your Capital
plan plan however you could also have
capital capital leases in which you want
to own that fir Tru at the end of the
term you want to pay for it for 10 years
but maybe in your community you can use
it for 20 because that piece of
equipment um isn't running constantly
and it it would
be useful it's useful life would in fact
be for 20 years so maybe you want to go
through the the bonding process given
its cost some I mean some of the fire
trucks are two and three million dollars
given its cost maybe you go through the
bonding process for that and it's not a
lease process at all right so I think it
really depends um there's several
Financial strategies that a community
could take to address its capital plan
and leasing is only one of
several follow up Mr go ahead so in
regard to that Capital Improvement in
regard to that Capital Improvement plan
there is no legal requirement though to
follow that plan is that correct that is
correct it should be reviewed year
over-ear to determine it's right what
what the needs are in the community and
if anything is elevated in that plan um
meaning well I think we can get some
more time out of the police car but um
the dump truck is sitting on the side of
the road and it won't turn on anymore so
I there's
absolutely it should be reviewed every
single year and adjusted for the needs
of the community thank
you for the
questions see on I have a couple quick
ones for you sure um you mentioned that
you were only speaking to the original
bill you have not seen the amendment yet
I I have seen I have seen but not enough
time because it really the amendment um
again and I will speak very just broadly
to it and the sponsors work very hard on
the amendment but it really gets into a
very P overprescribed way of leasing
because unfortunately there's not much
we can lease anymore for under $100,000
besides a a copy machine um so that
that's one piece of it it um and
certainly the other piece would be that
many communities do put it on the
warrant year-over-year there is already
um the law already requires you to have
your line item detail budget to the
level in which you sub account so it
could be five accounts down available to
the public so any lease in the budget
can already be removed out if it has an
escape Clause because again in year one
you would say for the next five years we
are leasing the following and in year
two if the Community decides whether it
has a warrant article or not there's
still a mechanism already that any voter
could remove it out of the budget
because it contains that escape Clause
it's already it's already within the the
purview of the law okay thank you and
the other question um going back to the
original B on lines 8 through 11 I think
you said it a couple times and I just
want to make sure you you didn't assign
a percentage to it but am I interpreting
what you've been saying that 99% of the
issues that the sponsor is attempting to
get rid of would be taken care of by
just striking that that's correct okay
thank you further
questions seeing none thank you for your
testimony thank
you hey I recognize this last name we
got one more pink
card Eric power you're
up school district governance
Association
you have the
floor thank you committee members my
name is Eric power from Brookline I'm
here in a couple
different capacities I'm the president
of the school district governance
Association who looks at
conservative uh spending and governance
issues with school districts um I also
serve uh on our Brookline planning board
uh they didn't send me I'm here
representing myself in that capacity um
but a lot of these pieces cross over
between towns and school
districts and um first thing I'd like to
say is I think that you know you've
heard today about RSA
337e while not doing things that are
illegal certainly stretching what the
intent of the law is by you know doing
lease agreements which are primarily
Renovations and throwing in a small
percentage of equipment to justify using
this RSA you know you can't return
Windows 2x4 drywall but again you're
leasing it with an escape Clause it's a
little bit uh
disingenuous in my opinion
um in our Hollis Brookland Cooperative
School District where I was um I served
in the school board for three years so I
know you know how school boards work and
the budgeting and all that uh two years
ago we leased for $2.9 million installed
HVAC and LED lighting with an escape
clause and uh for 15 years so obviously
you know it's not going to be easy to
return those sorts of things so
obviously that's another example of
what's been going on I think what's been
the reason it's been this lease with
lease uh lease purchase with the Escape
Clause has been used is because it's
easier to pass at the town meeting or
the school district meeting it only
requires a simple majority vote um it
doesn't even require a ballot vote if
you have a traditional meeting um the
example you heard about from T
Timberlane Regional School District that
passed by 55% so it didn't get the super
majority of 60% but the their TW their
20-year 24 plus million doll lease got
approved for essentially Renovations
with a couple of pieces of equipment in
there
um I think the $100,000 number was
picked because it's aligns with what the
standard is for bonds today and um the
other thing that's a little bit
disappointing and every lease is a
little different but if you look at a
majority of lease purchases that
typically cost cost taxpayers more money
not less because the interest rates on
bonds typically are more favorable so if
you think about it you're reducing the
threshold from a super majority to a
simple majority and you're costing the
taxpayers more money and they don't know
how much it's going to cost necessarily
so that's that's all u a problem that
the that this bill seems to be
addressing which is good um voters
really need an option to not appropriate
um I heard that that's supposed to be
the case but there's cases in which it's
almost impossible to find the least
piece of equipment to zero it out that
is not being followed and I think
putting this in this this statement in
the law would really make that clear if
there's really an opportunity to
non-appropriate it needs to be non
appropriable so it needs to be on its
own line item so that the voters could
zero it out if they would like to um I
think voters also need the full
transparency of tax the money that
they're appropriating in future years
and also the estimate of tax impact if
the voters have voted to have that
information realizing that taxes May the
tax rate may change but they're going to
get an update to that but in today's
dollars they would get that as they're
making a decision whether or not to vote
for that warant
article so um I would say if we if this
bill is passed by the legislature the
impact would be that this would stop the
renovations being done under lease
purchase agreements which is the big big
one is the big problem problem also I
think it is significant and you'll have
to discuss this is the 3- fifths super
majority a w a wise idea to deal with
equipment leases over
$100,000 um there I know being on the
planning board and doing Capital
Improvement plans every year as you
heard about I know there is a lot of
equipment that costs a lot of money but
again you're spending 600 700 $800,000
for a fir Tru shouldn't the voters have
a little bit more of a say than a simple
majority on those kinds of large
purchases and commitments even if you
can escape you're still spending money
on it um I was looking at our town
budget and we've had some of these
challenges Our Town budget is up 50% in
the last five years this is not really
sustainable and a lot of that's being
driven by lease agreements so um having
having that super majority would help
you know voters be able to say no to
things when they really truly can't
afford it so would ask you to consider
that um I would so I would say the
impact of this bill again would be to
also for projects that are happening
that are Renovations they will go
correctly through the bond process and
not through this least renovation
process so I see i' see there would be a
return to the right mechanisms for for
the uh the rsas that are out there for
these large projects for towns and
school
districts and the just to add a footnote
on the Thorton uh boiler bill I do not
believe that's been approved but it's on
their warrant for this year in
2024 and with that uh I'll answer any
questions thank you thank you for your
testimony representative
yella thank you uh thank you for taking
the question
um it seemed from your testimony that
you may have um actually seen the
language of one of these leases
um for essentially installed equipment
that had an escape Clause um can
you speak a little bit more if so um can
you speak a little bit more on what
exactly the Escape clause entailed and
what would be essentially returned if
anything so I did look at the one for
the least equipment in our Co-op School
District uh basically to escape you have
have to return the equipment so if you
know anything about HVAC and I was a
civil engineer in the military for 30
years so I know a thing or two you you
can return it but it's going to be very
difficult and it's not going to be worth
as much money um you're going to spend
more money probably returning than it's
worth LED lighting the same thing so
it's really not practical to do that but
that's what they say in there so it's
kind of a capricious uh
non-appropriation Clause it's one no one
would do not that no one the voters
wouldn't even want to do it because it
would cost them more money so yes but
they have to put that in there to get it
through this process of getting the
simple majority and leasing it and uh
having the card vote even I I think we
asked for a ballot vote in that
particular one because the voters can do
that at a traditional meeting but um it
didn't get a super majority I don't
believe thank
you further
questions being none thank you very much
for your testimony thank you
I have no more pink cards I have on the
blue sheet five individuals who signed
in all in
favor and with that we will close the
hearing on HB
1187 at that time we're doing good today
folks all right our next hearing starts
at 1 pm that'll be HB 1317 so we will
see everybody
then
it is 1 o'clock we're going to get going
now open up the hearing on HB
1317 relative to Municipal filings made
by Char organization exempt from
taxation I see the prime sponsor in
front of US Representative Maguire the
floor is your yours thank you very much
Mr chairman and members of the committee
for the record my name is Dan Maguire I
represent the town of Epsom before I get
started on this I would just wanted to
mention I was in your sister Committee
in the Senate this morning for a public
hearing and it struck me how none of the
five members of that committee are from
any town of of ordinary size right there
there's like me right I'm from a town of
under 5,000 people but but in that
committee the the
smallest um Community they represent is
Portsmouth right so I don't know I guess
it must be tough getting Town stuff
maybe through through that committee I
don't know anyways back to this so um
House Bill 1317 so um first of all I
just handed out an amendment because you
had a previous bill from representative
McDonald which dealt with the same thing
as section one of this bill the same RS
say so this amendment just deletes
section one right all right so we'll go
on to sections two and
three um I put in this bill at the
request of Mr Haywood um from the
assessing group and um he's here to talk
about it so I'm not going to say too
much but basically this is in in a
couple of very sort of narrow cases this
is to give Selectmen slightly more
flexibility over decisions that they
make um the first one in section two
changes a shall into a May which sort of
fits that sentence slightly better um it
it it allows it it's asking um Charities
who want to who want some kind of an
exemption they have to provide
information to the Selectmen
organizational documents nature of
membership function you know big list of
things and and it says there basically
if you don't have the full list of stuff
it shall result in a denial well maybe
somebody can't find this or has a little
problem with that or something like that
so this lets the selectman make that
decision and um the second part three is
to um add the not limited to errors
emissions and inability to pay to good
cause and so the idea there is um they
can again they can make their own
decision out what's what's reasonable or
what's not in in this situation when
they're giving an abatement so I'm happy
to answer
questions thank you for your testimony
representative Gallagher go
ahead um hi I'm Wonder or just looking
at this bill
um the part about um well it's just
feeling awfully familiar and I'm
wondering if you looked into to the
legislative history of um past attempts
to do something
similar
no representative
priest thank you for taking my question
and and welcome to this committee um
question is this a problem with
nonprofits in the State uh thank you for
the question representative um I believe
that Mr Haywood has a few examples of um
towns that he's worked at or been
familiar with that that have had you
know like Mason's groups and other
groups that have come into this category
yeah further questions uh representative
Brown thank you Mr chairman um so I
worked with the representative McDonald
on the first bill that you referred to
so I'm trying to figure out you said
you're deleting ing section one so as
currently written here in your bill
right if you you if you do ought to pass
with Amendment with that Amendment um
lines 1 through n will be
eliminated follow up Mr chairman go
ahead so one through nine would be
eliminated on this on what you're
showing here in this bill okay yes yeah
and
then may I continue Mr
chairman Maybe I can explain okay thank
you section one goes away lines 1
through nine the remaining sections two
three and four are simply renumbered
okay I understood that Mr chairman so
quick
followup uh go ahead so with this you
still leave in the highlighted portions
municipalities May charge this B that
you're saying correct no that's part of
section one okay thank you
representative
Elward thank you Mr chairman thank you
for testifying today excuse me do you
think that Charities who are on the IRS
Auto revocation list should receive tax
abatement U thank you for the question
but that's way over my
[Laughter]
head might want to save that one for
yeah somebody else representative power
thank you Mr chair and thank you for
taking my
question um on page one of the bill um
line 20 um it references the term good
cause there's a legal definition for for
that term and it depends upon the
context in which it's used could you
give me some specific um examples of
good cause as it pertains to this
section of our stat New Hampshire
statute
yes thank you for the question
representative but again I will I will
defer to Mr Haywood I think he'll he's
got examples and things that he's run
into in his work
so representative lales go
ahead thank you Mr chairman and thank
you for taking my uh
question
um does is there anything in statute
that you're a uh aware of that requires
for a charity to be involved in with the
bill to file the
necessary uh forms with the
state uh I know there are requirements
for Charities to
file uh you know as far as their income
and expenditures and so forth is there
anything in this that requires that
to give those to the town in order to
qualify for
this I don't know if that makes sense to
you yeah I I think it does and um I
believe that essentially every
corporation files with the secretary of
state or every business right charitable
or not I think they file file with the
Secretary of State periodically and so
um
so this if you if you read line let's
see this is existing law but uh line
um if uh if a a town wanted to if if
selectman wanted to ask for information
like you're talking about they could
require it right because it says and
other such information as be reasonably
required and so on okay you're right
right thank you very much all right
representative Gallagher you had your
hand up yeah um so I'm wondering um
about uh charitable gambling
specifically uh we had uh being from
conquered we had um a case with um a
charitable
gambling um operation
um exploiting some loopholes and uh tax
law and I was wondering if that would um
this this legislation would have any
sort of effect on that sort of case um
thank you for your question
representative I don't think so because
as I I only read about it in the
newspaper so but what I from what I read
it's it's strictly the problems there
were between the state the the uh um
Lottery Commission and the business and
and the AG and the business and this is
all about Selectmen I
think representative
power thank you Mr chair and thank you
for taking a second question and I'll go
back to that line 20 with regards to um
good cause has a very broad definition
and I'm trying to understand um the rash
now behind the bolded um language that's
added to the statute here
not limited to errors omissions or
inability to
pay why did you feel that that needs to
be specified is is there an issue thank
you for the question but I believe that
Mr Haywood had an issue on on a
particular case where um
someone uh had a good ex reason for an
abatement but it was not due to error
right it it or inability to pay it was
due to other cause
and and he'll talk about that I
believe are questions follow up go ahead
thank you Mr chair for taking the
followup so my followup to to that is is
in line 21 it says that select Minar
assesses May Abate
attack so they it's up to their
discretion so therefore in the case that
that um the particular case that you
referenced again it's up to the
discretion of of those people making the
decision thank you for the question but
again you're right they may if there's
good cause and if people think of good
cause as being errors emissions and
ability to pay right and they'll say
well you have a good cause but it's not
one of these three things right then I'm
sorry you see what I mean so that that's
the
idea further questions comments
I think we've rung all the juice out
of thank you okay thank you very much
representative I have one other pink
card on this bill Todd
Haywood thank you Mr chairman members of
the committee my name's Todd Haywood um
seems like it's been a week since I was
here last um as you as you may recall
but for anyone else that doesn't know
I'm a I'm a member of the assessment
Community I've been an assessor for 24
years have an assessing consulting firm
that represents or advises 11 towns in
New Hampshire um so this this uh kind of
result stems from um recent proceedings
which you may be familiar with or more
familiar with than you were a month ago
and there was a town that um that
granted um EX exemption to an entity
that technically wouldn't
qualify but they they're a charity so
they answer the question about if a if a
501c3 charity qualifies that alone
doesn't qualify you to be property tax
exempt there's a a statute that that has
a four-part test you have to be um you
have to own it occupy it use it for your
mission and your mission has to be
obligatory and benefit an indefinite
segment of the population so those
that's the four-part criteria I'm
paraphrasing the law so so just being
501c3 alone or a charitable trust member
at the doj alone doesn't doesn't meet
the test so in section two this seeks to
amend RSA 7223 C which allows the
assessors which are the Selectmen in
most cases to request additional
information from the
applicant but what it says now is if
they don't respond in 30 days they shall
be denied so you've recently been given
a a partial order from the board of tax
and land appeals in in this case that I
am referring to where they ultimately
did an audit of the
town's practices for institutional
exemptions and in many cases it's the
Consultants don't deal with it that left
up to the selectman because they've been
dealing with it for decades but since
this case it's become more to the
Forefront so what happened most recently
there was there were four houses of
worship churches and one charity that
had been receiving the exemption for
decades but because of this case we
asked them for their Articles of
Incorporation and their certificate of
good standing from the Secretary of
State well as you can can imagine and I
think there was some commentary here
that the you know some of the people
that are in charge of these Charities
aren't experts they're volunteers and
might be someone senior or in many cases
as I've found out if there's a change in
duties then the new person doesn't
really understand the process quite as
they should so in any event these four
churches didn't Supply their Articles of
Incorporation or U or certificate a good
standing within 30 days they did Supply
it but because it wasn't within 30 days
they were ordered to issue a tax bill
for the full year of
2022 so we think if if we say may in 22
uh 7223 C on as it indicates on line 18
of of this bill would allow the
Selectmen a little bit more flexibility
and hopefully they can use good judgment
when it comes to these type of instances
because what happened was is this which
this Segways into the next part section
three is B tax and land appeals said
initially in these proceedings that you
can't use RSA
7616 Roman number one to circumvent RSA
7223 so that leads the Dilemma so so
what we're asking is they say they say
or they said and they may have changed
their mind since then but they said in
January of
2022 that um that you can't do that and
then January 23 rolled around or
February 23 when these these entities
were issued a tax bill for the whole
year 22 they filed for abatement
naturally and then so the legal opinion
has changed and there's a differing
opinion the btla has said and it says in
their application that that that good
cause is generally errors omissions and
in inability to pay
that's not what the law says and there's
a difference of opinion among legal the
town's attorneys and I and like I said I
work for several towns Town's attorneys
May differ and say that you can you can
you have more discretion to answer a
question I think I heard from this side
of the room there was a bill last year
that you may have heard that was
proposed to mirror what the btla suggest
is is good cause and it was going to
insert errors omissions an inability to
pay and that failed and you you probably
remember that so this this kind of just
goes the other direction and allows that
flexibility for the local
assessors and I'd love to take any
questions if there are
any representative
priest thank you for taking my question
and thank you for being here can you
tell us more about those communities
that and the teral institutions that uh
this bill seeks
to um
resolve a remedy well I think we're
we're looking to have more flexibility
the the you know the 7223 is broken up
into six parts part part one and two is
government and and University part three
is the houses of worship uh part five is
the charitable and there's different
requirements for each
um this the charitables it's a little
bit more strict with them and I hope I'm
answering your question it's a little
more strict with them because if you're
religious we we know you're a church if
you're educational you're a school so
those are easy to identify the
charitables are a little bit more
difficult
because arguably is their mission
obligatory or not so that there could be
many that fall into that but just
because like as I said earlier just
because you're you're charitable 501c3
with the IRS doesn't alone qualify you
so there could be hundreds out there I I
I'm not sure i' I've come across some
that I don't think should qualify that
have been granted exemption for a while
and this is what I'm hoping that we can
clarify have
followup thank you for allowing me to uh
give a followup it's it's my
understanding that the Attorney
General's office that uh guides and
monitors the terriable
institutions um requires them to get a
certification on a yearly
basis so there shouldn't be any
questions is that correct well there's
I've reached out in the in my travels
over the last couple years around this
case I did reach out to the charitable
trust division they told me that not all
Charities do have to file the financial
form I think it's a nhct 12 is the
annual report and it's usually a
financial disclosure and and just
because you're like as I said just
because you're a charitable trust
doesn't Al qualify you for property tax
exemption under a Char
charity representative Gallagher um I
yeah I just uh want to thank you for
addressing the point about previous
legislation um in your testimony um I
was just wondering if you could uh find
the bill number for that um cuz I'd kind
of like to review my review my nuts from
last time to um refresh my memory about
why it was specifically we rejected that
I'd have to get it was HB 404 or 405 I
I'd have to double check on that one
okay thanks represent power thank you Mr
chairman I have a question but I can
answer I I have my own question but I
can answer that question it was 2023
House Bill
403 I think that's your reference thank
you so um thank you for taking my
question it it's a clarifying question
so I did um establish that good cause
shown does have a broad definition and
it's it's relative to the context in
which it's used so I think that I'm
understanding my previous questions to
the prime sponsor could you just confirm
that my understanding is correct and
that the reason why this language not
limited to errors omissions or inability
to pay is is to make it clear that it's
not in this Con to text just those three
things it
it the purpose is to open it up and
allow for those plus other um good cause
reasons thank you for the question and
yes it's exactly what the intent
is further questions
seeing none I have a couple for you
um the the incidences that you U talked
about that precipitated the change from
Sha to
May um to be clear were those a result
of the individuals not or Charities not
getting the paperwork into you within 30
days correct the charity at the charity
was there part of the bill that that
representative McDonald uh authored
deals with um the Charities and their
financial disclosures and given them
accident M mistake or Misfortune this is
similar because the the way the law is
written now there's no discretion it's
30 days or or you you shall be denied
correct
um and refresh my memory very quickly
what was the reason for they couldn't
get it to them in 30 days well there
were various reasons but more more
specifically I suppose that sticks out
in my mind is is they were they whoever
whoever was in charge of those documents
didn't know where they were and they
were looking for them okay uh the next
part yeah um I think it's would maybe
help to clarify for
everybody
um the words not limited to errors
emissions or ability to pay what that
line does in my opinion is it
delineates and explicitly says that
errors emissions and ability to pay are
considered good cause yet it is not
limited to those three items it's
exactly what it
says my question to you on that line
there
is explain to me inability to pay so
that's that would be an impoverished
person
um they the the selectman could wave
taxes if if someone had no money if
there was they were on the most likely
in my experience if someone were on the
verge of of losing their property and
being displaced they would for
non-payment of taxes they would they
would use that as a reason for good
cause thank you uh representative
Elward thank you for taking my question
thank you Mr
chairman um regarding inability to pay
um and being impoverished and on the
verge of losing their
status again if a
charity required to file say a 990 with
the
IRS um was on the A and had not done so
for three years and was put on the auto
revocation
list why would they want to Abate the
taxes I mean I I'm having a hard time
understanding so thank you for the
question my the way I perceive the
inability to pay as an individual like
someone that a resident that lived there
and not so much um not so much a charity
but I suppose you could you could take
that definition broadly and and apply it
in that case but if they were in if they
weren't current with their legal status
then that would PR preclude them from
being a charity
too followup Mr chair go ahead you said
someone might live there I I don't
understand so so the inability to pay
would it that's a broad term we're
dealing with property taxes and most of
the property tax payers are are
individuals that live in their
properties and that would be the case
that I've seen that we would use that
inability to pay pay for Mrs Smith that
was behind in her taxes in Jeopardy of
losing her house because for non-payment
of taxes I'm sorry I misunderstood thank
you further
questions seeing none thank you for your
testimony all right thank you Mr chair
and members of the committee I have no
further pink
cards and seeing nobody else looking to
speak uh we have on the blue sheet one
signed in and that was the individ uh
individual who just testified Todd
Hayward for and none against with that
we'll close a hearing on HP
you
okay uh we are going to go ahead and
open up the hearing now on HB 1459
relative to
policies that
or yeah policies that municipalities are
preempted from
enacting
the only sponsor on the bill resigned
his um position last week because he
moved
so we do not have a prime sponsor and
typically in this committee is when we
don't have a prime sponsor we have
somebody introduce and unless somebody
really really wants to speak to it we
will immediately close it and dispose of
it at a later
hearing so um I'll ask somebody one of
us wants to go up there
and all
right
and we have representative yo Kella who
will
introduce thank you Mr Speaker or Mr
chair Mr chair um I'm here to introduce
HB uh
1459 to uh the committee
um and
uh I'm happy to uh say
that uh this this bill can
die so I don't think anyone needs to
speak further on it
byebye let it
off I do have one pink card do you wish
to speak to it
Nate
okay very
good okay having no more pink
cards uh blue sheet that's
empty we will go ahead and close the
hearing on
HB 1459 relative to
policies preempted from
enacting and we are well ahead of our
next wow and unfortunately for those
here for cac1 16 we cannot begin the
hearing until the published time of
going here one of the clocks say 2:16 so
we are ready
to
go almost
okay uh gonna open up the hearing on
crc16 relative uh relating to local
governance I'm not going to read the
whole thing I'm sure you all will talk
about it I see representative qu up
front you are here to introduce I
expect floor is yours hearing's
open thank you everyone thank you very
much Mr chairman I am Jim qua State Rep
from ringe over by Mount madok and I
represent ringe Jeffrey in
Dublin I I am here to introduce cacr 16
a constitutional amendment to basically
restore and preserve local control of
zoning and land use
policy uh although I'm not the author
the author is actually the honorable Jim
McConnell two term former State Rep also
retired usami Colonel I'm sure he
actually needs no introduction but
uh uh he'll be speaking to this in more
detail when I'm when I'm
done I sponsored this bill for two
reasons it's it's my view that land use
policy is it needs to be inherently it's
inherently
local uh I also think it should be
stable with changes in this policy uh as
is generally the case now made only with
local
approval now I say land use issues are
inherently local because the local
residents of an area are the most
directly by land use policies and have
to deal with the consequences of those
policies
directly also the local residents are
the most familiar with the local
environment that in impacts land use
decisions and also the conditions under
which they live now I'll give you an
example of that kind of familiarity I
come from ringe ringe is on the Divide
between the Connecticut and the marac
watersheds those of us who live in Ren
are well aware that all the water we
consume or
use uh derives from rainfall because
there aren't any uh there's no flowing
water there's no streams or rivers that
flow into
wrench and so we always have to be
concerned when discussing or reviewing
potential developments in the town
where's the water going to come from so
that's an example of the importance of
local familiarity with environmental
conditions uh so to my view the best
policy decisions uh regarding land use
are made by those who have a good
knowledge of local factors are directly
accountable to the voters the local
inhabitants and also share the
consequences uh in New Hampshire we have
a long tradition of local elected land
use boards in in ringe for example we
have planning and zoning boards which
are accountable to accountable to the
local
voters uh in in ringe I I I looked at a
number of the uh older annual reports
the furthest back I could find a
reference to zoning uh zoning commission
and zoning ordinances en ringed was 1954
70 years ago uh classical three score in
10 years almost you know
lifetime uh in the old
days uh and one of the one of the early
lessons I learned as a selectman was
that when somebody was
unhappy with a planning board or Zoning
Board of adjustment decision typically
people would come to a selectman and it
was important to explain to them that
the people making this decision weren't
the select board but they were their
locally elected planning board and
Zoning Board and it didn't make him
happier with the decision but at least
they understood that they could in the
long run
influence uh the people making the
decision through their
votes uh the reason I think
that uh zoning uh decision
General land use
decisions need to be stable is that for
most of us most people their single most
important uh decision in their Liv
financial decision is buying a home it's
the single most expensive investment
most of us make and it's also an
investment that directly impacts the
quality of our
life uh based on our local
environment so I think people should be
able to expect stability with land use
uh policies changed only with local
Ru now I think that policy which as I
said has long standing in New Hampshire
of local control needs to be restored a
bit because of the
recent uh introduction of the housing
appeals
board which instead
of uh the decision path going from uh
planning board to zoning Board of
adjustment if necessary or to a judge in
this Superior Court there's now this
housing appeals board which as near as I
can
tell uh is not accable to voters in any
way since they're all
appointed and since they're not local
they don't have to share any of the
consequences of the decisions they make
I think
that's uh not a good
development
so uh that's my statement and
introduction I going to defer questions
to the author of the bill uh former
representative
McConnell and I will stay a little bit
but I need to get back to the election
law committee meeting I'm in well thank
you very much for your time and thank
you for the opportunity to speak to this
Mr chairman thank you for your
testimony okay we will call up uh
honorable Jim
oon
welcome former rep
McConnell thank Mr chairman members of
the committee I wondered why I hadn't
heard it in any event it's been a
while um you have testimony in front of
you which some of you have already read
but basically I can quickly go through
this cacr gives municipalities sole
authority to establish zoning and land
use policies briefly the amendment
provides that municipalities determine
the policies for projects they're
willing to consider should a developer
seek a waiver to those policies the
voters consider the waiver at the next
municipal election it's been suggested
that municipalities already have the
authority they need but legislation's
frequently offered which suggests
otherwise this morning for example SB
538 L which is sponsored by 10 state
senators Was Heard by the Senate's
election law and Municipal Affairs
committee a portion of the Bill's
analysis reads enables municipalities to
allow its governing body to adopt
certain zoning ordinance changes and
adds additional Authority and Zoning
powers for parking requirements and
lotsize requirements related to sewer
infrastructure once
cacr 16 is adopted the state's 234
municipalities are free to establish
policies designed to be either welcoming
unwelcoming or anything in between to
devel developers this flexibility is
demonstrated by S SP 53 538 L's
significant departure from current state
imposed requirements the most welcoming
policies can be designed to ensure that
waivers are rarely required should a
developer seek a waiver from
municipalities policies CA cacr 16
stipulates requirements which ensure
local control importantly including a
financial impact statement listing any
projected tax
increases statements
um which voters may consider in voting
to approve or disapprove the requested
waiver adoption of CAC R16 makes
development easier to attract in those
municipalities seeking development and
at the same time protects those
communities which wish to retain their
current character I'm the author of cic
R16 I'll be happy to answer your
questions uh the text following this is
uh basically an oped that I wrote in the
conquered monitor back in August and or
yeah the conquered monitor back in
August and essentially explains my
thinking on all of this so I will be
happy to take any
questions okay represent
power thank you Mr chair and thank you
for taking my question so the the prime
sponsor of this legislation um made
mention of um he's from a small town out
in the western part of the state and um
their community that they're concerned
about the supply and the quality of
their water so and that's one of the
reasons why he said that you know this
bill in this bill the purpose is is for
land use to be local because people
local understand the needs so my
question is is with regards to any type
of development is not Dees involved um
with regards to um permitting
or the the the the um the water use
because a lot of our municipalities um
are not on public water and SE or they
have their own private Wells so my
question
is I'm trying to under because that was
a concern and I think a rationale for
what why this legislation is important
but I'm just wondering is there already
a check and a balance not that I'm aware
of in that respect because and I served
for four years on the resource
Recreation development committee and was
deeply involved with Dees but I'm not
aware of the fact and I could be wrong
on this but I'm not aware of any
requirement that Dees sign off on any
particular
project representative
majori thank you Mr chairman and thank
you for taking my question um I'll say
many because I don't know that it's all
communities uh have Master plans and I'm
curious how this parallels Strays from
collides with or whatever your your
interpretation might be with a
community's efforts to put this kind of
information into a master
plan well yes I guess most of them do
have Master plans there are 234
different commun municipalities in the
state and obviously this would provide
an opportunity for any municipality to
revise
its master plan and the guidance that it
wants to offer anybody who is coming in
as a developer as to what they're
prepared to consider and that being the
case this gives them an opportunity to
redo that with this in mind now it seems
to me that a development that a
community should they wish to be
welcoming to developers can basically
fix it so waivers would almost never be
required they can make it extremely
Broad and make it very easy for a
developer to come in and do almost
anything he chooses to do within those
guidance within that guidance
the uh by the same token the other side
of that blade because it cuts both ways
is that if you choose not if you were a
rural community and choose not to have
much development you can say okay we're
going to make it difficult for developer
because we are sufficiently dense and
like ringe we have a water problem we
want to be very careful about what we
bring in here the bottom line is that's
under our control and we can make it
very hard for developer as well so you
can make it very easy or very difficult
and to my way of thinking everybody
should be supporting this and should be
bipartisan a town like Manchester or
NASA and I've written to both of their
Mayors so I don't know if they've said
anything to you but they haven't said
much to me but the bottom line is they
have flexibility here which witness
Senate Bill 538 they don't have now and
if this passes they're going to be able
to make it very welcoming to developers
so I appreciate that the state has a
housing crunch as does most of the
country and we're not the most extreme
example by a long shot from what I can
see uh they'd be in a position to make
themselves very welcoming and proceed
with development at a rapid
Pace representative
El thank you Mr chairman and welcome
thank
you
huh um so there seems to be opposition
to the housing housing appeals board
appeals board which after a zoning board
decision um an applicant K turn a butter
May appeal to either the superior court
or to the housing appeals board
correct I don't know if the housing
appeals board has an option where you
can go to the superior court but even if
it does the bottom line is the housing
appeals board rules with the developers
something like 98% of the time I'm
told you're told by who sir by reading
it in the newspaper okay thank
you represent Gilman
thank you Mr chair and I will tell you I
have several questions but I'll ask one
and then uh maybe somebody else will
follow up um one of the questions that I
had thank you for for uh taking my
testim giving your testimony is um on
line six where it says project seeking
changes variances or
waivers
um
well will this lead
to uh going if all is going before the
um
local legislative body um what do you
see as far as Town meetings that decide
this are we going to have make the uh
applicant wait a year or um have several
special meetings for a project no the uh
there'd be a one-time opportunity for
citizens to vote at the municipal
election for any waivers requested so
should a developer come to the community
in June and
say I love your project I love the
project as currently written I've got
plans that can do this in a heartbeat
but I really can't live with two stories
I've got to have four well obviously
that presents some problems potential
problems in any event he seeks a waiver
so if he does proceed to seek that
waiver he'd have to presumably pay the
municipality for the preparation of the
financial impact statement he'd have to
provide them with all of his details and
all of that in and and be willing to
answer any questions as they go along
but that information would have to be
prepared 45 days prior to the next
municipal election so if he comes in
June seeking a waiver he won't get it
until that March election but the bottom
line is that if the community is
sufficiently welcoming and is anxious to
have that project they could have
written that into the uh plans in
advance now something like that with an
increase for example of two stories to
four there are all kinds of problems
with that potentially I mean the fire
department takes a look at it and says
we don't have a hook and ladder
trailer okay we're going to have to have
a garage for that hook and ladder
trailer if we get it if in fact we need
to we put in a four-story building we
may need a bigger water pump pumping
machine uh truck I'm not a fireman so I
don't really know but the point is that
all of those things would have to be
taken into account and you know the
police department comes along and says
well you're going to double the capacity
of that building that line that road
that runs to the main road can't have a
stop sign anymore it's now got to have a
regular traffic light there's going to
be all kinds of additional costs that
are involved in this and those should
everybody should see those eyes open now
offsetting that of course is the fact
that the project is now twice as large
large as it was so it'll have more
Revenue coming in from taxes but is that
sufficient to offset that nobody
knows but that's that's how this would
work representative
F uh thank you Mr chair thank you for
your presentation former
representative um my question I think is
a
followup
um you you talk about
um waivers and zoning ordinances or
changes to land use
regulations may not be considered
without the approval of all Civic
veterans fraternal not for-profit
Association Property Owners
affected
um by that statement in the uh in the
document do
you do you mean that that a planning
board cannot even take up the issue
without the approval of all of those
groups I'm saying that any one of those
groups could stop the project at any
point should they determine that they
have been influ been affected for
example the ladies Garden Club even
though it may not be in a butter they
take a look at the project as it's
presented and determine that their
Gardens are going to be their growing
gardens are going to be in Shadow for
half of every day of the growing season
are clearly affected the developer
should have to make his accommodation
with the ladies Garden Club as opposed
to vice versa he can't just say well
ladies tough luck and that to some
degree is how it goes right now the
other thing is recognize the portion
that says as affected I don't see this
coming up all that often if you're a
Veterans of Foreign Wars and you're 10
miles down the road on the other side of
a mountain and you want to claim that
you're effective I think that's a
stretch and I don't think that's going
to hold up at all I think everybody
throw that one out in the heartbeat
uh
followup go ahead uh don't these groups
have the opportunity to um weigh in at a
planning board hearing or a zba hearing
for example they probably do but if
they're it may not become apparent
immediately that that's the problem
either way they're going to have to sign
off on it and if somebody figures out
something like for example the ladies
Garden Club determines that their Gard
are going to be in Shadow half of the
growing season that's a problem that may
not become immediately apparent but the
point is they are in a position where
they will have to require the developer
to accommodate their wishes as opposed
their concerns as opposed to Simply
lumping it now as I say I don't think
that's going to come up all that often
because you generally have to be
affected and I think those things will
be apparent fairly quickly in most
cases represent
gager uh so the previous testifier the
prime sponsor testified that it was his
opinion that um land use policy should
generally remain stable um is that your
stance as
well generally it is yes but if your if
your if your community determines that
it has to be changed then they should be
in a position to change that if they
find that they're getting way too much
development in the way of applications
or way too few then they may want to
change it
um so followup um so if um so yeah I'm
basically just responding to the part
where you said yes um so if when use
policy should in fact remain stable then
um how is it supposed to react to
dynamically changing situations such as
the current housing
crisis well the community involved would
have to determine as to whether not not
the housing crisis affects them directly
I mean if you live in a you know I've
got four pages or three pages or
something here about zoning and the US
Supreme Court decisions that that affect
it uh the local community should be
making those decisions themselves if
they once make a decision they should
obviously see how that results most of
them I would anticipate would make their
decisions and they would remain with
those decisions for some
time whether they want development or
whether they don't
representative
PRI thank you Mr chairman for taking my
question and thank you for being here
and for this very thoughtful bill so let
me just
recap uh with the situation so a
developer comes to your local town and
he wants to build this development but
this town but the project is not
compliant with the master plan or the
zoning and the town does not have the
adequate
infrastructure to serve it so they deny
the project and the project appeals to
the zoning board and the zoning board
denies it now they can go to the housing
appeals board to present their case and
the housing appeals board can approve it
putting the town in a very awkward
situation is that a correct assumption
and this is what your bill is trying to
to add I think it's a correct assumption
I mean you've gone through a couple of
steps there but bottom line is this bill
cuts through all the rest of it and
basically says this Constitutional
Amendment those things in the law which
currently conflict with this new con
with this Constitutional Amendment right
are wiped off so that so the housing
appeals board would if
this um yes yes is approved this seizes
and they say the state does not have any
say in the local what happens in the
local governments right in yes
absolutely okay great that's the purpose
of this thank you so
much
representative thank you Mr
chairman um on line six and
seven it says project seeking changes or
variances uh to the zoning ordinance or
land use
regulations may not be considered or
approved without prior approval
Etc does this now the zba is EMP
currently empowered to Grant variances
and special exceptions so would this
strip the zba of that power to Grant a
variance yes
thank you I mean the bottom line is that
the only variances that would be
permitted were this to be adopted would
be those at the municipal
election that's local
control represent Gilman thank you Mr
chair and thank you for taking another
question um I'm going to follow up on
two questions
um one is
um on that same line about
um variances and waivers and listening
to um the Civic veterans and fraternal
organizations why does it not include a
Butters why does it not include a
Butters yes prior approval of a Butters
there's no reason why a municipality
couldn't add a
Butters this this is the minimum
requirement okay follow up Mr chair
absolutely go ahead um it's been my
experience here for almost 8 years that
anytime we bring up a zoning ordinance
change it has failed in this committee
for just the reasons you're talking
about do you see that being a pattern
that um is ineffective or needs to
change you mean the current procedures
uh the fact that the history of of
zoning Statewide zoning changes
have not succeeded in this house well
this isn't a Statewide zoning change
this leaves it up to each of 234
municipalities to determine what their
zoning policy is the reason that I
included all of the federal laws that be
on zoning is because should this be
adopted those would be the laws that
would
apply the municipalities here in New
Hampshire would be free to determine
their own
course period okay thank
you represent Brown thank you Mr
chairman thank you for taking my
question so I'm I'm new to this
committee this year this past year so
I'm trying to understand what you're
trying to do here because my
understanding is New Hampshire is not a
home rulle state right that the state
delegates its auor its authority to the
municipality so what you're saying by
doing this is it's it's delegating this
authority to each local municipality now
well you're talking about Dylan's rule
yeah and in my under in the information
following my
testimony um you can see the actual
dillan's 1960 or 1868 decision which
spawned Dylan's Rule and he says
basically that municipalities are
controlled by the state their very
existence is controlled by the the state
unless there is some constitutional
limitation on the right this is a
constitutional amendment for exactly
that reason this is not a bill if this
is adopted as a constitutional amendment
it wipes out any bill that conflicts
with it that we have adopted over the
course of however long we've adopted it
this changes everything that's the
point Thank you Mr so I think you just
answered my question so what's happening
now is the state is relinquish
relinquishing its Authority in this
regard to the municipalities is that
correct only if I can get it through the
New Hampshire House of Representatives
with a 60% vote and the state supreme
court with and the the state senate with
a 60% vote and then it is up to the
citizens voting in the next general
election this November 24th November of
24 uh to approve it by a 2third majority
so constitutional amendments are not
easy to implement and that's the reason
why I mean everybody has to think about
this one and this is a big deal and it's
a big step bottom line
is the governor talks about local
control and then he comes up with a
housing appeals board okay fine well you
know I tell you I'm 8 feet tall too you
know but the bottom line is that you
want local control this is local control
now I tend to make this an issue on the
next election if it doesn't get through
the bottom line is the toothpaste is out
of the tube on this a lot of people here
don't realize that uh in Dylan's rule
you know the phrase unless there is some
constitutional limitation on the right
changes
everything and that's right there in his
decision so yes this is a constitutional
amendment changes the procedure leaves
it up to the 234 municipalities in the
state
they can draft whatever they want to and
there is a procedure if someone comes in
Seeking a
waiver now there may be a better way to
do it I've thought about this pretty
hard and I don't know what it' be to
ensure the local control is maintained
that's what this does thank you
representative
power thank you Mr chair and thank you
for taking my question so on page one
lines seven and eight beginning with the
Clause without the prior approval of all
Civic veterans fraternal and not
for-profit Association Property Owners
I'm curious I'm looking to understand
why those particular groups are cited in
I'll have a followup after that well
that's straight out of U I think it was
nectow uh one of the Supreme Court
decisions
basically um they're pretty close to
straight out of it um
the difference between by the way
there's a difference between not
for-profit and nonprofit and the
nonprofits are basically the uh uh 501
C's of which there are about 25
different categories but in any event
the not for-profits of the little guys I
offered the example of a ladies Garden
Club for example what are they going to
do if the developer says too bad well
they're out of luck but the key point is
if affected they have to be
affected now of course there's the other
side of the coin somebody's going to put
in massive development and I own a
little tiny piece of property or I'm the
president of the American Legion we've
got a little tiny piece of property we
look at this project and say we're right
at the corner we're going to be in
McDonald's we'll be able to build the
biggest American Legion in the world if
this gets in so there are two sides to
this
coin follow up go ahead thank you Mr
chair and thank you for taking my
followup so it says without the prior
approval so I'm curious to understand
what what that approval process would
look like that approval process would
look very simply like you come in and
approve it and if you if I were a
developer I'd go in and say give me a
list of
the veterans fraternal not for-profit
Association property owners who may be
affected by this and I'd contact all of
them if you if I contact the sons of
Italy down the road and they say we have
a problem with it and here it is you
know if they say well we don't like you
being in our ZIP code well I'm going to
say well terribly sorry fellas but if
you've got a problem where it's going to
screw up your access to your project or
take half your your baseball field or
something like that they're going to
have to come up with some sort of an
accommodation in any event the long and
the short of it is the developer the
onus is on the developer to accommodate
the local community and if the local
community chooses to say not only are
the not for-profits covered but also so
nonprofits it should be born in mind
however that nonprofits are awarded that
tax exemption by reason of the fact that
they provide a significant Community
good think the Red Cross think the Boy
Scouts that's not a little league
proposition I mean these guys are
serious and they've got some muscle but
the ladies Garden Club they don't have
any muscle at
all representative
correct thank you for taking my question
um if I understand this
correctly um the terms imposed or
allowed should this amendment um be
approved by the voters of the
state would they apply equally to an
individual land owner who wanted to
let's say he had 50 acres and he wanted
to break off 20 to give to his son
and in order to do that he needed a
frontage variance would that particular
land owner be subject to the
same criteria for approvals as the
developer who needs the same variance
for a
150 apartment building complex this
relates only to land use and to zoning
so in other words if you own 100 acres
in wish to give 5050 acres to your son I
don't really see where that changes the
land's use necessarily now if you give
it to him if you give him the 50 acres
and he suddenly decides he wants to put
in something obviously that's going to
have to be considered in the light of
the requirements that the that the
municipalities imposed followup
please um so I'm talking strictly of a
variance for a frontage
requirement never mind find what the
ultimate use of the land is going to be
although in my hypothetical I did give
you two examples the question involves
that variance in the zoning regulations
for a frontage requirement would they
apply equally to me who wants to give 10
acres to my son and would they apply
equally to the developer who needs that
variance for his 150 unit apartment
complex I'm not sure I understand your
question if you're saying first of all
there 234 minp alties determine their
own
policies so I'm not sure why you need a
variance if what you're saying is if
your property then would no longer have
a 100 Acre Frontage it would only have a
50 acre Frontage and then your son would
own a separate 50 acre
Frontage obviously that reduces the
the ability of that piece of property to
be sold for a large project because
there are two owners to be involved but
I don't really
see where you go with that if there's no
variance
requirement it's up to municipality is
basically the way I see it maybe I'm
mistaken but go ahead
uh go go ahead
Julie uh I yield to my colleague no you
may not representative
kale thank you Mr chair thank you for
taking my question you stated earlier
that um about 95% of the time the
housing appeals board has ruled in favor
of the developers is there any
particular situation um that they have
done that that is egregiously you know
of that is egregiously cost taxpayers of
a municipality like in a scenario that
representative priest was describing
like with with infrastructure like an
extreme burden put on is there a
specific example that that has caused
well I think you're going to hear about
one in a few minutes from the uh one of
the planning board members in Swansea
who's going to talk about that but I'm
sure there are at some point I mean the
municipalities have opposed these things
um and that's why it's wound up before
the housing appeals board um there was
one in I think eping just the other day
I maybe it wasn't eping but in any event
representative Gil
thank you Mr chair and thank you for
taking another question okay I'm going
to follow up on uh representative fra um
question about uh subdividing a piece of
property if my zoning ordinance which is
voted on by the legislative body
provides that a a housing unit or piece
of property needs to have 50 foot of
Frontage on a street before it can be
developed and what he has explained is
dividing 100 ft into 50 ft would that
because the zoning ordinance says You
must have 50 ft not 100 feet you've
divided so now they're changing what the
property is being changed to meet the
zoning ordinance okay it's a change so
do they have to go they would require a
variance to do that or sub subdivision
lot subdivision would they would they
have to wait for a town meeting in order
to actually adhere to the zoning
ordinance I don't see it that way that's
not the way I wrote it the bottom line
is I don't see the change in the land
use I mean unless you're saying when
when I talk about land use I'm not
talking about ownership I'm talking
about land
use and uh you know there's a big
difference it seems to me I mean if I
want to build
something uh that should be subject to
the approval of the town and it should
be
consistent with their master plan or
their guidance whatever they've provided
for developers if I look at it and say I
can do that that's
fine assuming I can do it without a
waiver then I should be free to do that
and I don't know where the 50 and the
100 come into that to be quite candid
depends on the
project well depends on depends on the
way the town chooses to put it can I
follow up Mr chair yes go ahead
you just said it depends on the on the
zoning that's in the town that the town
chooses to adopt right so I'm
sorry the so if if a town has already
adopted that zoning then why do we need
this amendment and why do we need this
Constitutional
Amendment because current well the
community is free after this
constitutional amendment is adopted to
develop whatever policies it chooses to
develop that's why I say there are 234
communities and the bottom line is that
once well once those policies are put
down you'd need a variance if it changes
the land
use but you're not changing the land use
from where I'm sitting and I don't think
that's what the law would require either
and I've read a ton of stuff about
zoning
so represent power thank you Mr chair
and thank you for taking another
question so it's my understanding that
the housing appeals board makes the
decisions in a very narrow framework and
that is they they look at the appeal and
they make their decision based on number
one are the New Hampshire statutes being
followed yes or
no is the local locality following their
own ordinances yes or no or are they the
local boards are they just making things
up as they go along and it's the wild
west so that's a very um specific and
narrow
criteria um for which the housing
appeals board makes their decisions um
is that your understanding as well my
understanding is the housing appeals
board makes a decision based on what
they wish to
do now to my way of thinking it
generally has to conform with the
current laws but by the same token they
remove the local aspect of this in large
measure now those policies I sat on a
planning board and we would adhere to
exactly what the Law's requirement was
so there were many cases where we
weren't happy with a project but we
approved it in any
event now you're going to hear from a
member of the planning board in Swansea
who has something like six or eight
years experience on the board and he's
seen a lot of this and a lot of projects
that have just come in here in the last
couple years years they're changing the
character of the Town dramatically
that's not an isolated case there are
plenty of those around the state so I
can't tell you exactly what the the
requirements of the housing appeals
board are but I do know that there is a
lot of dissatisfaction across the state
from a lot of people in a lot of
different towns who spent a lot of time
working on
this and obviously it's better if they
decide instead of the housing appeals
board thank you Mr chair and thank you
taking my followup so I hear what you're
saying is that the the dissatisfaction
comes in when the local control or that
local aspect has been
overridden yeah overridden what whatever
adverb you want to um choose so then is
is not the real issue some of our
statutes that we have on the books that
that that
don't that don't um point to or allow or
enable the local control it's more of
the state
saying that's why this is a
constitutional amendment because it
clears all of that
up thank you representative uh
priest thank you for taking my question
and um and thank you for allowing me to
question again um what I see in this
bill is a way for local
governments to buy bypass their
responsibility for let's say building
affordable housing if a developer comes
into your community meets
your zoning master plan infrastructure
but the town's people are saying we
don't want those kind of people living
in our
community and so they deny the project
because of their income structure so
then this developer can take your
community to the housing appeals board
and said look we've met the zoning we
let the infrastructure but they don't
want the prospect of those people moving
into your community is that a correct
assumption no to my way of thinking this
allows the community to lay out its
guidelines if as you suggest a developer
wishes to come in and develop Workforce
housing if it meets the guidelines it
should go through like through cous
Bingo now there shouldn't be a whole lot
of trouble assuming that the developer
meets the financial requirements to be
able to complete the project and all the
rest of the requirements and it should
go through the process of providing all
the information to the town and
everything else but if it meets the
guidelines that the community has set
forward in advance then there's no basis
to deny that and that's what they've
said they want it yeah now this will
permit the developer of the community
rather to deny developer the developer
the opportunity to build
if he has to go in for a waiver and the
community chooses to turn it down now
there's the other side of the coin they
may choose to go ahead with it but it
also provides communities which are
anxious to have Workforce Development to
provide a guideline which makes it very
easy for a developer to come in and very
quickly build exactly what you're
talking about so as I said this makes it
really easy for some developer for a
community that seeks development to get
it they don't have to go to the state
for all of the things that are requested
in for example 538 they can just proceed
to lay it out developer comes in says
great I can do it I want to do it I meet
the financial requirements give you all
my plans and everything else everybody
says yep meets all the requirements have
at it because they've in effect asked
developers to come in and do precisely
that if however you are a small rural
rural community and you wish to remain
the way you are I have absolutely no
problem with them saying single family
homes 10 acres on Case Closed to my way
of thinking it falls to the community if
you're a community and I've as I say
I've written to most of the major mayors
of the state with this I don't know what
they did with it but I have talked to
some of their people about it and
basically if somebody says we want it
this makes it easier to do it I
appreciate that the community and the
business community in this state is
looking for more Workforce housing this
doesn't prevent that it prevents it in
certain communities that don't want it
but the communities that do want it can
have it in
Spades representative
majority thank you Mr chairman and thank
you for taking another question um would
would this amendment eliminate the need
for a designation of regional impact
what would Regional impact as far as I'm
concerned it would okay thank you I mean
this this the whole purpose of this is
to leave it 100% in the hands of the
towns
representative thank you thank you for
taking the question so you keep on
talking about the local tyranny that you
want to allow with this however in lines
9 through 15 you're essentially
mandating those um municipalities to
have a certain uh
process before they approve and so
you're you're saying that you want to
allow the local tyranny in some senses
and then you're forcing them to abide by
your uh approval process for another
sense so I'm just wondering your last
statement you said I want
100% uh flexibility for those
municipalities but in this article
there's not 100% flexibility so I'm just
wondering uh why you um oh but there is
so if you're a municipality you get to
decide your policy period there's
nothing in there that says that they
don't have to wait for the 45 days prior
to adopting the vote so this this line
on uh line 10 to 11 they don't actually
have to abide by that requirement in the
in your constitutional amendment the
amendment the amendment permits each
locality each municipality and we have
234 of them to make their own policies
it doesn't say you have to have this you
have to have that you have to have the
other thing there are 234 different
solutions to this problem it seems to me
the difference I think is that I'm
talking about a waiver should a
developer come in look at the
requirements that are stated and seek a
waiver if he seeks a waiver then he has
to go through the procedure stipulated
if he doesn't seek a waiver he is
presumably going to be approved the
develop the community will in effective
ask developers to come in and meet those
requirements he meets them he
builds seems to
make represent
FR thank you Mr chair thank you for
taking my question
um listening to your testimony and your
responses to the questions of my
colleagues
I I can only only assume that the
purpose of this
amendment arises or the the reason for
this amendment arises out of
your
dissatisfaction with the decision record
of the housing appeals board in the
appeals process and as such you want
to base basically throw out the baby
with the bath water uh would that be a
correct assumption not entirely I'm
certainly not happy with the housing
appeals board so I can agree with you
there but the fact is that this sh this
is real local control and the first
question I went to was whether or not
Dylan's law Dylan's rule had a provision
in there which I found right there in
the paragraph that matters unless there
is some constitutional limitation on the
right I believe in local
control
period
followup go ahead follow up uh thank you
so might it
be a a better course of action to
examine ways in which the housing
appeals board can be fixed rather than
to try
to that doesn't that doesn't no I don't
think so that doesn't address the issues
for example in 538 I mean you've got a
bill there which seeks permission to do
any number of things which this would
give a municipality the authority to do
right off the bat and that's not the
only Bill that has come along like that
there are many of them they come up
every year so the truth of the matter is
if I were the mayor of nashille or
Manchester or conquer or any other major
city in the state who presumably seeks
um development have indicated they do
anyway I would think this is a great
idea bottom line is I'm going to be able
to DET turn my own policies I don't have
to ask for anything from the state of
New Hampshire I can get right to it I
think that's a pretty good idea thank
you rep sorry
represent thank you Mr
chair thanks for taking my question
can
you what do I want to call it graph it
or give us the line diagram of when the
contractor comes in and guest Den I you
know and bring it all the way to the
other end who makes the final
decision the final decision on the
waiver if he seeks a waiver the voters
make the final decision at the municipal
election in March who's going to sign
off on it who's what who's signing off
on
it the tally at the end of the day on
Election Day I mean you either have the
60% of the vote or you don't if you
don't Project's denied the waivers
denied excuse
me so in other words if you come in as a
developer and seek a
waiver you tell the community I'm going
to seek a waiver Community is going to
say well we have to prepare that and
there's a $5,000 charge whatever give us
all of your data we'll proceed to
process this put it together have to
complete it before 45 days 45 days in
advance of the municipal election and
then on the municipal election date of
the municipal election the developer
gets a decision it's either approved or
it's
not follow up Mr chair go ahead thank
you
um but in the
end it's going to come back to somebody
to take possession of it or take you
know if it goes to the president or the
Supreme Court or whatever they make a
decision and the voters make the
decision yes if it's if it's approved
then you give the green light to the
developer and have them start
digging we'll talk about
it representative
G um so you said this could be used by
both pro-development communities and
anti-development communities I'm
wondering which of the two positions
towards development would you consider
to be more common or likely to occur
among New Hampshire
communities well I there are 234
municipalities in New Hampshire and a
lot of them are very small and I don't
think they're particularly friendly to
the idea that somebody's going to come
in and change the character of their
communities but okay so followup um in
terms of percentage of the population
hold
on when a question is asked let the um
witness or the testifier finish first
and then we can follow up in terms of
the population that's affected uh it
seems to me that a very large percentage
of the population in the cities in large
measure would um you know find that
they're developing because I I
understand that that's where most of the
desire for development is but a
community that seeks development in
Peterboro for example they're doing a
lot of building they're happy to have it
that's great now the
followup
so
um all right actually never mind I lost
my TR
thought okay repres representative major
thank you Mr chairman and thank you for
taking another question um piggybacking
a little bit on representative Tetro so
the if I understand this correctly is it
true that the legislative body would
approve this this
project the registry of deeds then has a
project that is stamped in some way that
says approved at town
meeting because the registry of deeds
needs a myar that says some that says
it's approved approved I'm just trying
to figure out how the regist doesn't get
approved until if if a waiver is sought
it doesn't get approved until the voters
approve it and
how CLA so what would the registry of
what would be on file at the registry
pending
pending I mean it's there's no it's
approved sorry well if if the guidelines
that the state that the the municipality
puts out require a waiver
then it can't be approved until after
the voters have approved it if the
voters approve it if they choose not to
approve it then it's not
approved until then the property stands
as it is I mean if you're asking what's
the tax status of it stays in the hands
of the current
owner further
questions seeing none thank you very
much think got one over here oh I'm
sorry represent Gilman
thank you Mr chairman thank you for one
last question um I'm going to follow up
on representative Major's uh
comments you understood that a myar or
final or a drawing of a project needs to
be uh stamped as pending before a
decision is made by the legislative body
no before the decision is made by the
voters well they're the legislative body
in technical language here um so after
that
vote it's approved but what is what does
the registry of deeds going to have on
their drawing to prove it's been
approved we need like right now you need
a stamp of an engineer or
architect that says it's approved by you
know planning board or whoever so the
how who's in control of the project
after the voters vote after the voters
vote the decision's
made but how do you prove it I'm sorry
Mr chair the vote the vote is they
either approve it or they
don't that's why this is a
constitutional
amendment that's how you do
it representative
fra U if I may perhaps rephrase the uh
the question of the last two
speakers
um as chair of our planning board in in
the town of Enfield okay once we approve
a
project I have to sign a myar which then
goes to the registar of
Deeds what the two previous speakers are
asking I believe is once the voters
approve of a project which requires a
variance or a
waiver who signs the
my whoever would sign it before it's now
approved the voter look that's why this
is a constitutional
amendment okay bottom line is until the
voters move on it there's no decision no
final decision if they seek a waiver now
if they don't seek a waiver there's no
problem it's exactly the way it's
supposed to be now just goes right
through that's why this is a
constitutional
amendment the new requirement is right
here
further
questions I see no more could I ask
before you run away though I'm not going
to run
away from what I've been trying to
gather here that a a lot of
the or a good percentage of the problems
uh that you suggest are out
there is the is found in the housing
appeals board is that correct just yes
or no no they're an example of the
problem okay the problem here is that
the local community I spoke to a
resident of I think it was Sullivan the
other day he said my taxes went up 25% I
didn't see that
coming point is this should all be up to
local control something that changes the
nature of your
community if it doesn't fit into exactly
what you've laid out in the way of what
you're prepared to consider and accept
should be subject to the
voters correct 234 communities or
municipalities don't they for the most
part and I know what you're trying to
accomplish I get that but for the most
part don't those 234
municipalities already have the ability
to determine their zoning
regulations most of them do but the
point is that they are being overridden
by the housing appeals board that's a
significant issue and that's not my only
issue okay but hold
on but that has been the response I've
heard on a lot is the housing appeals
board my question is by it let's just
say this bill was to eliminate the
housing appeals board would that
solve 90% of the problems it solve a
good part of them but I don't think it'
solve 90% would Sol a significant number
to my way of thinking the the approval
process I've heard from I've spoken to a
number of towns about this and some of
the people in the town say yeah you know
what regulatory capture is well that's
when a town that's when a governing body
gets taken over by an industry and the
developers own our Z zoning appeals
board now they've got the ability to
change that at this moment but the truth
of the matter is this is a cleaner
easier way to do it and we get rid of
all of the options or all of the
difficulties at the moment with the
municipalities seeking State approval
for this that and the other thing they
can do that their own okay all right
seeing no more questions thank you very
much for your testimony we are going to
move on Philip Sherman than you
dcrb Mr chair members of the committee
uh name is Philip Sherman the chair of
the building code review board uh most
of you know we developed the state
building code for ratification by the
general court I speak in opposition to
this bill primarily due to what I think
or hope are unintended consequences my
comments arise because many of the
municipal actions relative to building
codes reside in the RSA 670 series on
land use this proposed Constitutional
Amendment would require that a project
seeking a change a variance or a waiver
to the code would require approval of
the parties named in the bill would
require a financial impact statement and
then require it be approved by
three-fifths of the voters at the annual
meeting the building and fire codes
currently permit changes to the specific
requirements of the codes based on
modifications to the code or
justification of alternative means and
methods and in fact the fire code
permits variances through the State Fire
Marshall each of these routs is reviewed
and approved by officials knowledgeable
of both codes and construction a local
and state appeals route is available
involving local Boards of appeal many
times the zba and the State Building
Code review board and then on to the
various courts from there a constit this
Constitutional Amendment would for the
most part effectively remove the ability
of a proponent to utilize better more
cost effective or more technologically
advanced means of construction or to
deal with conditions that were not
contemplated by the codes somebody comes
up with a new kind of water faucet that
hasn't been approved by the codes yet
would wind up going through this process
because they'd need a change to the
specific words of the code I recommend
that this bill fail but if it must pass
please consider limiting it to zoning
issues not land use issues in general
thank you I'm happy to answer any
questions
other
questions seeing none thank you very
much you're
welcome uh next
up Kristen
Reynolds
hi so I'm just speaking speaking for
myself I'm a member of the public and I
moved to New Hampshire a couple years
ago from Portland
Oregon I recently went to a deliberative
session first time I've done that in my
small town and I loved it it was so
impressive it was definitely democracy
in action and I had a chance to go over
the
budget carefully and hear from the
people why the budget was the way it was
and it turns out we're really poor I
can't believe how many things are so
incredibly expensive I had no idea and
they were talking about trying to find
like a used truck of some kind you I
think they had a plow or something they
needed and they're like well we've been
looking for a used one and we're trying
to get a grant for this truck I was like
it was an eye opener for me so actually
I thought we had local control it's
really been a new information for me to
find out that the state can decide
things for the towns and I can see all
kinds of problems with that immediately
and of I've been walking past uh a new
development uh that is on Route 10 on
the way to the post office and every
time I go by it I kind of wonder what
does this mean because it's a lot of
people all of a sudden in this one
little area and it's going to mean
something in terms of traffic who knows
if we're going to need to have a new
traffic light I mean it's it's an
unknown and it's the kind of thing that
I would really want to be locally
figured out locally decided and have you
know just have the the ability to
control how fast things happen What
Happens can our taxes cover it Etc so I
just wanted to say I do support this
bill I support anything that uh is local
that that creates local control for
things that matter a great deal to me
and to the people who live in our town
so thank you so
much thank
you seeing no
questions Mike
York
afternoon everybody thanks for hearing
us um I have been an eight-year member
of the Swansea planning board hav been
the vice chair a couple of
times uh my citizens in my town are
coming to us and wanting more local
control right now Swansea is about 7200
people in buts Keen which is a larger
municipality and they're busting it the
seams we understand that but we don't
feel it is the people in my town don't
feel it's their responsibility to build
housing for the city of Kean so that we
can incur all the cost that comes with
more people while King gets the benefit
for these people to work in their
town now we have not been we have been
very generous to this point of allowing
uh multiple housing in the we have over
500 units have been approved in the last
two
years okay on the planning board what we
go by is our zoning regulations the rsas
that are involved and a site plan we
have one project in town that's gone
through um legal problems I can't speak
a lot of it right now because it doesn't
not have final approval and there's
always a possibility it could come back
to the planning board or the zba in some
manner so I can't really speak of that
right now but there is an issue there
now with Jim's plan this this
Constitutional
Amendment uh then the state would have
less authority over us they would the
habb would basically go away which is a
good thing because there are many many
cases and I can't cite them I should
have brought a couple today where
they've overridden the intent of the
planning board when they wrote the
zoning and the people approved
it this also the case I'm talking about
in Swansea involves Superior Court and
New Hampshire Supreme Court which you
would think well that won't go away yes
it will because the courts are going to
have to obey the Constitutional
Amendment we know that they'll have to
do that and they
would um but that it's all about local
control now we don't turn down what we
do is I look at
project and I try to be fair to the
property owner
and follow all of our rules and
regulations we have this last year had
these Pig pares come in and people are
coming to the board and testifying to
the planning board that they want to
change the zoning which we're doing but
the fear is in most of us is that
eventually the state can say wait a
minute we don't still don't have enough
housing in the
area so we're going to put these other
legislative that will actually do away
with our zoning override our
zoning uh what comes to mind was last
year was fortunately was able to shut it
down as s sp44 which would allowed
four houses built in one
lot okay this year it's come back to
1291 where additional Adu units can be
built which just creates the same thing
of higher
density now Swansea has a density of
about 165 people per square mile so
large town landwise is 45 square miles
Kean has one over
600 what I'm hearing from my citizens
who I have to answer to they don't want
a higher density because with higher
density comes more crime so you're going
to have to hire more police officers and
every town out there can tell you right
now it is very difficult to get police
officers people don't want to do it
anymore because all the stuff that's
going
on um it would require us to go to a
full-time police uh fire department well
there is not a more
expensive uh Department to run the a
fire
department with a town that size with
three
firehouses we would have to qu triple on
the amount of our equipment and our
firemen right now we're just trying to
get a fire new Fire Station built
because the old ones under the town hall
shouldn't be there anymore because it's
a it's a safety issue
and I think I can answer one
representative's question she had right
away is if the town voted to allow the
variance it would probably have to be
still signed by the planning board chair
like it is done now because there has to
be a signature on it when it goes into
the into the
county and with that I'll take questions
represent PRI thank you Mr chairman for
allowing me to ask a question and thank
you for being here and for your public
service in Swansea I really appreciate
it and to the previous speaker welcome
to New Hampshire you're gonna love it
here um question it sounds like Swansea
does not want multifamily housing not
anymore no we just approved 500 that's
going to be another thousand to 1500
residents thank
you representative power
thank you Mr chair and thank you for
taking my question I understand um what
you're um expressing to the committee
and your
concerns and it is my understanding
correct it sounds like that the your
concerns really stem
from leg legislation that has been
signed into law
that reduces or takes away local control
with regards to you know housing and and
development so my question is and and I
understand that we have this cacr in
front of
us could one another way to to deal with
this um issue this concern that that
some municipalities have is through you
know the legislature and who you um send
to conquer State reps and Senators
because it sounds to me like the the the
root cause is what what's being passed
and and signed into law is is that
correct well what what's happening is
the people in my town in a way and I'm
sure there's plenty other towns when
they leave the decisions completely to
the state legislature they feel like
they don't have control they're not
going to come up here and confront you
people although they should we should
have had a thousand people out here for
this bill and every bill it goes out
there but they will come to the local
planning board they will come to the zba
they will come to the selectman I would
like to see more people come to us so we
could develop the town the way we you
know they wish but they don't they
scream at us to get something done now
we have a the 27th we have a meet the
candidates for local Town elections and
I'm hoping a lot of people come there
then
further
questions I have a couple for you sir
certainly um you talked about your town
uh becoming a call it a bedroom
community of keen by the sounds of it
um how
many you've been on the planning board
for a while in the last few years how
many projects of any size have been
approved been given final approval
outside of your Town's own approval
process in other
words I'm assuming your zoning allows
for everything that has gone
on has there
been any housing appeal board's decision
that has overridden your decisions not
not the habb but there is one Court
ruling from Superior Court and supreme
court that we lost I can't speak a lot
of it because that's the case I'm
talking about about it's not a final
approval yet so as you know a planning
board member has uh expart requirements
where we can't talk about it sure
understood but there is one
there okay so as
a you can't mention how many or whatever
um but is
it is it fair to say that the majority
of projects or um housing or whatever
that has gone on in your town been
approved yes because we follow the law
and your zoning ordinances well yeah
that we call that the ordinances yes and
don't get me wrong I understand local
control okay
um the other point or question I would
ask is you mentioned several of the
bills last year and this year that have
come before us um it's my understanding
correct me if I'm wrong that most of
those bills actually got shut down in a
very
large manner is that correct that is
correct and hopefully that would
continue however the people that are
comli of the legislature now may not be
here in five years they may decide to
retire make get beat at the polls
whatever you may have a complete
different set of legislators who decide
well we don't think they did the things
so let's go do with these and pass them
and I don't disagree with you that kind
of goes back to representative Powers
suggestion though it's kind of who you
send I think but this this would be kind
of a guide a guard against that also y
uh representative priest I sorry hand up
yes thank you for taking my questions
and thank you for taking my additional
question um you believe in the
Constitution and the fact that we have
checks and balances and that right and
if a person is griev d by local
controls let's say the zoning he can
always appeal it to the
courts and have his case heard with this
Constitutional Amendment that takes away
the checks and balances for that person
is that
correct yes it would take away those
checks and balances um but it's with the
towns now instead of the
courts further
questions represent
t
thank you Mr
chair
um one I I'm I'm trying to piece
together from
the The
Proposal
um contractor comes in and this is this
is a question in the end it may take me
a second to get there but
um
and people complain about the whatever
it doesn't get approved so it goes
through the planning board
process
unapproved but then your local control
you're telling you're telling your local
control and people to run for these
offices nah we didn't like that answer
we want an answer from this
group now um that's why I asked earlier
since you've taken all these other
groups of elected officials out of the
line who's responsible for it in the end
in in the end if it's voted looking for
variance and the first thing is they if
they bring a project to the planning
board or the
zba and it doesn't meet it needs a
variance they're told it needs a
variance so then they have to apply to
the town if the town votes to approve
the variance then it would have to be
signed by the planning board chair on
the
mara but he would have to sign it he
would have no choice sort of like when
the planning board approves one now the
chairman has to sign a
myar thank you you made make
Point representative
L thank you Mr chairman and thank you
for taking my question
do you you must feel like you're on the
front line of a
giant tug of war right now yes but I'm
used to that I'm I was a marine for
eight years okay thank you very much for
your
service um a constit constitutional
amendment is rightfully is very
difficult to achieve you have to go
through a lot of steps
steps to get it done and and that's
correct in it doing that yes I
agree is there something short of a
constitutional
amendment that would meet your needs
there on the front
lines um I don't know because anything
that the legisl ler would pass would
still be challenged in a court or the HB
it could be challenged because what the
HB looks for I've looked at a lot of the
cases they look to see if there's a
commonness placed they look well how can
we they don't look to see should they
approve it if everything is followed I
looked at how can I not approve it I've
been to their
meetings okay one in case is continuous
uh Road Frontage as we've talked about
here is um one Z in thing is how much um
continuous roage do you
have uh Frontage on a on public road
well if you don't put continuous in
there you could have a piece of property
we have a lot of weird properties in
particular in Swansea where a person own
this part of the land then he doesn't
own this part of the land and it goes
back just a little bit then he owns
another part of the land and this is all
connected well the
intent of our zoning and we just changed
the continuous if it doesn't say
continuous in there but the guy has
enough Frontage adding up those two then
they'll approve
it so it's yeah we've been meticulously
trying to go through our zoning to make
sure the intent of the people is
there but then again at any time the
legislator so wants to they can take
those rights away if you would have
passed legislation to say we have the
power you can then turn around the next
session and take it get
away thank
you repres Gilman thank you Mr chair and
thank you for taking another question um
with your experience on the planning
board uh you understand the process of
making changes to the zoning ordinance
that the um changes are rep represented
to voters uh at the annual meeting so my
question is why e either with a project
that uh needs approval by the
legislative body for a uh change because
they want a variance or or or is um
waiver that can only happen once a year
how is it that those changes can't be
made by the planning board because they
have to do it once a
year you understand either way it's once
because the planning board although it's
a representative of the uh legislative
body
still it's it's uh seven people six
regulars and plus the selectman's uh
representative it's a representative of
the town okay but when you got a town
with 7200 people and we have 4600 voters
I believe was the last count um they
don't necessarily you get it
right because sometimes in a lot of our
our meetings we have nobody there we do
zoning we start zoning usually in the
middle and our site plan regulations
usually in the middle of the year so we
can go through it give our public uh
hearings but people don't always show up
but what they'll do is after you've done
something they'll
complain and I'm sure you people uh at
the legisl have the same
problem we have never seen that happen
sir representative kale um thank you Mr
chair thank you for taking my question
thank you for coming out here today um
to kind of echo my colleague's
sentiment um about is there something
that you can do other than a
cacr correct me if I'm wrong but can't
your
town put a stop to building permits if
there's a legitimate no infrastructure
problem can't you just say hey we're
going to pull a halt on building permits
well if we if we did that like that then
it would go to the HB or the courts and
they would say yo
hostile and they would L follow
up what what if what if you had a
legitimate reason like a leg if you have
a legitimate reason if you have a
legitimate reason under the zoning
ordinance or the site plan
regulations then um you are usually on
Good Grounds but it's it's very
difficult sometimes if you got one word
wrong and this is basically what
happened with this this other case that
I can't talk about one word wrong and we
get
overruled although the tent our tent was
quite
clear further
questions seeing none thank you very
much for your testimony I have one more
pink card thank you Mr William
Rogers thank you Mr chairman thank you
all for your service I come out to
testify for things once in a while and I
can't believe what you guys go through
for the state for for the little bit of
money you get so thank you um I'm just a
citizen I don't belong on any committees
um but I'm a taxpayer and my taxes are
getting harder and harder to pay every
year I live in a small town of
Winchester I'm sorry my name is William
Rogers I live in
Winchester
and my fear with I approve I I I'm in
favor of this this Constitutional
Amendment
um and let me tell you
why we have a housing crisis in this
country right now we know that there's
been millions of of people have come in
and we know the federal government's
going to want to find places for these
people so they're going to go to the
states the states are going to want to
find places for these people so they're
going to go to the towns and they're
going to go to the
towns and My worry is that they go to
the towns with a heavy hand and say you
have to build this many houses in your
town and because their only focus is on
housing under a crisis which I believe
we're in and will be in their focus is
on housing they're not going to take
into consideration the schools the taxes
the the fire engine the infrastructure
the price the goes along with that
housing and representative
priests it it's not about we don't want
those kind of people in in our town um
we're Americans these people are here
whether we believe they should be or not
they're here and As Americans I believe
we're going to find places for them and
that's important but we also have
to think of of our taxpayers of
ourselves my taxes are so high I can't
imagine that they're going up in our
town I know most people I want to make
improvements to my property but I'm
afraid to because of what it'll do to my
taxes and I'm worried about more
students and forgive me but the higher
up the chain you go I trust the federal
government way less than i t trust the
state government but the people I do
trust are the people I see on the
streets every day in my planning board
in my zoning board when I can go to the
town hall and have a conversation with
them that's important to me um we'll
find places for these people but we
can't we can't break our whole our whole
towns into that and I don't believe
there's any way a state can know
whatever any any state politician can
know every challenge that every town
faces so it needs to be up to it should
be up to local control during this
crisis because I'm afraid like I
said we see a housing crisis we'll be
focused on that you'll feel pressure
from above you're going to put pressure
below and I just don't think that's
right so I'm in strong favor of this
amend thank you for your testimony
representative
P thank you Mr chair and thank you for
taking my
question um currently under New
Hampshire law
section 674 colon 23 titled temporary
moratoria and limitations on building
permits and the approval of subdivisions
and site plans so there what that means
is municipalities can adopt an ordinance
that limits the issuance of building
permits and put a moratorium on on
building I would like to know has your
town um ever enacted or made use of that
tool in the toolbox not that I'm aware
of no um and it it sounds like it would
it' be an all or nothing if they put a
moratorium on permits then
perhaps the the development that makes
sense for our town would be under the
same
moratorium as as the the development
that would break our
town represent kill thank you Mr chair
thank you thank for taking my
question have you personally conveyed
your feelings about this to your state
representatives I believe I have yes
I've I've spoken with
Jennifer
times further questions representative
Brown thank you Mr chairman uh Mr Rogers
I'd like to thank you for your testimony
I know you were hesitant when we first
first spoke and I think your testimony
is uh very sincere and important to our
committee so thank you thank
you seeing no other questions thank you
very much for coming and your testimony
thank you all I have no more pink cards
so I
believe uh on our blue sheet we have
three signed in two in favor one
against and with that we will go ahead
and close the public hearing on C
a16 so for the committee um as of now
next Wednesday will be our next
Gathering well as a committee um next
Wednesday at 9:30 a.m I believe I
scheduled it for yeah we will be doing
half day of exing and a half day of
public
hearings so with that
we'll see everybody
later